[Music]
is
there's no time
lost the time is 13
[Music]
o00 hey it's us all right and we are
back it's [__] Saturday man Saturday
and got I got the drinks mostly poured I
just got to make mine and get to it I
just got done with a damn chicken salad
sandwich I made I he was like yeah I
don't want to drink on empty stomach
inhaled it I was like Jenny you want a
chicken salad sandwich he's like nah
well you could you wait till the last
minute I didn't I didn't think about it
till the last minute but I had
everything ready I could have just made
it you know I had a little tiny piece of
coffee cake but that was a long time ago
okay trying to being in a calorie
deficit yeah yeah Jenny and I are both
like on a diet we're always on a diet
well [__] all this [__] fantastic
food re eating you got to like you know
what I mean you got you're the one that
went to Sam's and got like three or four
gigantic boxes of little Debbies I know
that and then he comes back and I'm just
like you're sending me mixed messages
it's like do you want to not be fat or
you want sit around eating little
Debbies is the thing you don't have to
sit around and eat little Debbies just
little Debbies are in storage you know
what I'm talking about you're only like
130 calories per little [__] Debbie
okay per Debbie per
[Laughter]
Debbie and I eat like maybe one or two
of them a day you know what I mean like
for dessert you know or like a little
snack or something afternoon mhm yeah
with a high protein diet so it's not
like you're sitting around like back in
the good old days when we're 13 just sit
there and [__] eat like [__] a
whole box of little Debbies you know I
you know what even in my little fat kid
days I never I never did that I wasn't a
fat kid I was a fat teenager you're just
lucky I didn't get any of those Dad
[__] Nana Moonpies
well that you could have got some of
those cuz you would have eaten all those
cuz I don't like
them they didn't have banana moon pies I
looked for them I bet you did [__] man
Jesus Christ well that's that's what I
mean you can get those because you can
eat those I mean and you got the ones
you got you got oatmeal cream pies which
I'm not really like a big fan of yeah so
um the zingers are good and you got like
the they're not little Debbies but their
Hostess like little coffee cakes it's
just like a little square of like
Cinnamon Streusel yeah they're they're
90 calories or something I 110 calories
calories so it's like the same as pretty
much like a bowl of oatmeal yeah it's
what you yeah not nutritionally but
calorie wise no but I mean calorie wise
but it's what you put like in a little
kid's lunch yeah that's what I that's
what I got them I got them I just had
one of those early I had a cup of coffee
and I had one of those microwave it in
the package for 7 seconds and it blows
up like a little [__] balloon and you
come out it's all hot and steamy yeah
like it came out of the oven it's hot
and steamy hot and steamy you know about
it trying to get sexy with me getting
sex with me on [__] Line This is
we're live right now we're live I can't
do anything about
it let's see what everybody saying what
we got got 24 in there right now they're
piling in everybody hi everybody piling
in okay yeah off to a good start talking
about food now all we need is Pooky
shoving her butt into the frame yeah she
just went out of the porch though we're
going to go get her I'm going to go
check her later like uh when we do a
break in debah hacket Sabrina's in Jetty
Jetty fren bees nest is in Oracle M's
here Maria is in Maria SAR she really
enjoys hanging out she says sad they
have to leave in an hour so caregiver
stuff that's okay you can watch it later
Maria yeah it'll be there um hopefully
yeah talking about Midwest Outlaws
talking about Cosmic Brownies I don't
know that one they're the ones they're
brownies like the regular brownies which
are actually really good they're really
dense but they have like um multicolored
like star-shaped sprinkles on the top
that's what makes them Cosmic Joy Joy
saying uh she started her fudge round
addiction all over again we nut we we
still have nutty bars in there too I
think there's a box in there that's like
not even opened all right I haven't
eaten one of those for a while I did
have like a little bitty coffee cake
today but that's all I've had out of the
Little Debbie stash you know what I mean
all right gotel Angel if you got a big
box of zebra cakes then we'd be in
trouble because I'd be wanting to eat
those all the time Celtic Angel this is
the first time they've been on made the
live streams that's good
woohoo uh yeah these are usually super
fun as we get drunker and drunker
progressively over the course of the
show four down said when Tom hits 300 lb
he can wear from home you talking about
300 lb in weight or you talking about a
300 lb bench
press because I was coming up on 300 lb
bench press but uh I started to falter
and then I went back to [__] lighter
weight and more reps but uh I need to
heal up 100% take another run at that
300 lb press the most I've been able to
do is I think
275 lbs was it about right I think it
was about 275 that was the last time I
spotted you yeah and that was that was
about what five months ago maybe it
probably went up I have no sense went I
mean like I know what day of the week it
is cuz I have to because of you know
which show goes up and I have to keep
track of that [__] uh yeah Michael
Schaefer says Christmas tree cakes are
my favorite those also kickass those are
kind of like well those are basically
like the Zebra Cakes just in a Christmas
tree shape and with green sprinkles on
the top so you know Joy Joy says she
loves those o oatmeal cream pies and
those nutty bars Bella uh Howers spurger
I hope I spell that's a that Germanic
ass name howb howb man that's like the
name of a replicant or something
from um she likes those nutty bars too
they they really are good and well cuz
we were afraid we hadn't I hadn't had
little Debbies in like [__] I don't
even know how long like probably 20
years so he brought the The Nutty bars
home first like last time he went to
Sam's or the grocery store or whatever
and we were like worried that they
wouldn't be as good but they're actually
really good I think they they even
improve them a little bit the peanut
butter is not so crumbly and dry as I
remember it's like actually decent
tasting peanut butter and the chocolate
is decent tasting too not so waxy so it
seems like they have improved it Mark
saying he was benching 285 in high
school and squatting 500 that's pretty
good that's good figures back in my high
school there was like only a couple guys
in the 300 PB in the 300b bench press
Club they put their name up on the wall
in the gym there was only a couple guys
and it wasn't me I was a lightweight I
was little back then you know it wasn't
I didn't really get into physical
fitness right until I [__] started uh
doing military service you know in the
Infantry that's where I got interested
in it and in the Infantry in the time I
was there short-term power and
bodybuilding wasn't what you wanted you
wanted endurance and you wanted some you
wanted to be small and kind of [__]
uh um you know good condition in your
muscles so you can recover quickly it
just a big muscle takes forever to
recover yeah you'd have to be like lean
yeah you had to be like lean cuz like
you said a lot of what you did was like
endurance Marching for for hours and
hours and hours walking and walking and
walking with your own body weight
strapped to you right um little did I
know you know [__] like special
forces units especially [__] like
[__] sfod you know Delta Force
they're like SWAT teams those [__]
were all on roids yeah yes uh so so were
the [__] seals they're on performance
enhancing drugs they just kind of kind
of have to keep it low they don't tell
you that you have to it's just that if
if you haven't figured out that that's
what you have to do then you can't be
one of those guys uh so they keep all
that [__] down low They Don't Really
drug test for it but they're they're
professional athletes they're just
taking it and it's not like they're
cheating because they're not in a sport
the shit's for [__] life and death so
they're like you do what you have to do
those [__] are taking all kinds of
[__] yeah yeah Celtic Angel 73 says love
listening to the episodes at work it
makes the long and sometimes Lonely
Nights at work more bearable oh than I
love the banter between the two of you
that was the original concept of the
show yeah I mean that's what we wanted
to do we just wanted to make it like
because that's you know we just wanted
to sit here and like talk to each other
and then like talk to you guys out there
and it just it worked out we my our
original concept was like you know we
could just be like professional friends
really because there's so many people
because you know when I came up
listening to radio listening to Howard
Stern I felt like I was part of the show
everybody that listened to Howard Stern
felt like they were part of the show but
it wasn't online there was no
interaction so you weren't it was an
illusion
hey there's Pooky there Pok but with
modern technology the audience can be a
part of the show we can see you if
you're if you're on live so you know the
torch is being passed on to a younger
generation radio and television and all
that [__] [__] theater is going out
man so everything's going to social
media this is the media of the future
well and all of the show I find that all
of the shows that I like on YouTube are
either um people telling scary stories
like from Reddit which I love those I'll
listen to those for hours like while I'm
doing other [__] but I also like stuff
like beer and board games um welcome to
the basement which is movie review show
which is just two guys hanging out like
talking about movies doing a little bit
of riffage on there like like MST kind
of Riff tracks so I like that kind of
stuff I like cine Massacre um you know
more the guy because he also does Angry
Video Game Nerd I'm not really into a
lot of video games so they're funny but
like I don't you know relate to them as
much but like all his horror movie [__]
I I I like that best part of the new
social media way of doing it is that you
don't need big sponsors as long as
you're not pissing off YouTube and
patreon you're you're you're going to be
okay pretty much evidently and you can
you don't need a million people you
don't need a million listeners so you
don't have to water everything down to
appeal to everybody you can Target it to
people who are like you and are into
that same [__] and you can make a decent
living off of a few thousand people and
only like a few dozen good patrons
that's [__] you can the show comes
worth it yeah and like I said we just
initially started doing this cuz it was
kind of like fun for us to do yeah and
merch you know what I mean we had robot
merch but made by the damn robots but
the the handmade merch that were selling
like this shirt and then the other
shirts I think it's more popular and I
think it's a better quality product and
it's a lot more you know it's I like
that we actually started doing those
we're making them me and Jenny make them
yeah they got your name on it a little
Tagg and we're [__] no we know who
it's going to and everything yeah I just
buy the shirts the blank
shirts.com
and
and we go to the FedEx office up here
the and print it on transparencies and
we make the we make the screens in that
closet right over there with a little
hanging light bulb Y and make the shirts
in the kitchen yeah on the island in the
kit and then heat treat them with the
heat gun and then we blow with the heat
gun and if there's any problem just
contact us I'll [__] replace it if
there's a problem you know if it was our
fault well we'll do it yeah I don't mind
because I always have extra blank shirts
because every time I do an order from
jippy shirts I always order like extras
of all the size especially medium that's
what he want if you put drop $20 in the
comments or send us $20 just tell tell
me what you want I'll send you a shirt
uh we still have one person who paid who
hasn't gotten back to us with what what
their size is well they were actually um
no they did because that person did but
the the one person that I was talking
about was on patreon okay and they just
joined patreon like tier all right and
then I asked them like what what their
size and stuff was yeah I have the
address I just don't have the size or
the shirt that they wanted okay but he
hasn't answered no do you remember who
it was Mark Mark Mark Navaro that's Mark
Navaro okay he's got to contact us well
he's on Patron just leave him a message
yeah yeah yeah that's what I said cuz I
I emailed him I messaged him back like a
while back and said um you know what
size do you want what design do you want
yeah cuz he paid we just got to know
what it is want what what he wants
Michael Schaefer says I found the
channel looking for a review of the
movie a boy and his dog I was hooked
after that yeah you know um all the you
know branching out into the movie
reviews was another idea I came up with
and Jenny wanted to do it too because we
like movie
reviews we fig because I love horror
movies and we watch like I love horror
movies and I've seen pretty much all of
them so it's like when it started the
show I was think trying to think of some
way to advertise the show besides the
show
itself but realized we tried to couple
these little [__] little short things
that didn't
work really worked I think those those
top five ones that I did I like the way
the videos came out they were cool but
it's like they were so labor intensive
it just seemed like they didn't get any
hits so the way to go is actually just
movies movie reviews got more attention
oh Mark says that's me sorry I'll
respond yeah there you go yeah there you
go I got your [__] man just send tell me
what it is you want just tell me what
size you want and what uh design you
want if you want a logo you want a pkin
one you want a um whand one yeah wayand
I got I got way we do we still have the
old the 13:00 the 13 clock one that
looks like the Friday the 13th poster do
we no don't have that one you don't have
the screen anym don't have the screen
anymore oh what' you do with the screen
uh uh put one of the newer designs in
that screen to free up more because I
mean we could make another one because I
have another transparency of that I
don't think it I don't think it looked
as good as the new ones let's just make
Victor he says I need a shirt give Pooky
$5 okay all right all right we will just
make sure let me write that down let WR
write your name down and then make
sure send us a uh send us a private
message on Facebook or whoever however
instag on Instagram tell tell me what
shirt you
want what shirt do you want Victor give
me your shirt your
size and then give me your uh give us
the address separately depend I mean
depending on what size it is it's like
it we might be able to do it sooner
because I have a bunch of extras back
there and like some sizes but if it's
some sizes we have some sizes I have I
think I have oh I can't remember I think
I have some larges and some mediums I
think maybe an extra large but I'm not
real sure okay but if not I mean Jiffy
shirts is really quick whenever I've
ordered for them usually when I order
from them I get the [__] the next day or
the day after that yeah a couple days
later we actually get get a shirt but we
have some shirts and stuff oh okay
thanks okay I'll take another shirt
please wants a whand a whand one okay
you want a 2XL okay whand 2XL yeah okay
I might have to get a blank for that I
don't think I have one of those but yeah
no that's a special order and Mark Mark
also I might have one but I'll check he
wants another shirt which one you want
Mark which shirt what
size what no one's talking it's dead air
dead dead air Man this ain't radio I
know well that's why I said it and then
laughed CU I was like back in the old
days we had have [__] worried about
that but yeah we have I mean we have
everything to do it like I said pisin
selling hot our new 13 o00 the the round
one that one's selling a lot man I'm
going to do some more like uh shirts for
myself with that design on it cuz I like
how that came out if I do say so myself
yeah do another one do another one like
that do another 13:00 one of your choice
like that with a real cool symbol yeah
this do do something like that yeah okay
love the on air sign by the way yeah we
like it too yeah thank I just painted
that today that was Tom's idea he
painted it well because the outside was
like I guess somebody made that with a
3D printer 3D printer yeah so uh the
outside was silver which was fine but um
actually no it was like a shitty gray oh
was it okay it a shitty gray and I was
like that and light would shine through
it well because
where it was uh you know so I I masked
it off and spray spray painted it in
matte black to hold the light in and
then sprayed it spray painted over the
matte black and Onyx green onyx metallic
green cuz that's all I had it was a damn
car paint yeah a Dodge paint so use that
he's got all kind of car paint yeah got
car paints and all kinds of [__]
motorcycle header paint yeah all right
what you what you want Mark you're not
really answering well wait he might be
like he might be on a phone I want to
know what what shirt design you want
what size you need
make sure you send us your damn address
so we can so we'll ship it out well he's
on patreon at the $20 tier his address
should be in there okay because I asked
everybody at that tier to put their
address in there okay all right so it
was in and almost everybody did okay
Celtic Angel says the first video of
yours I watched was the episode on Galo
movies oh okay yeah good that was one of
my favorite ones to do and it's like you
know what I mean it was funny because I
feel like like Tom doesn't know a lot
about him so it was mostly just me
yammering Mark wants a 2X L pliskin and
dealer's Choice okay 2XL
plin yeah because he had already and
dealer's Choice okay so I'll just I'll
probably send a logo
one yeah because I asked him before
about the money so he just sent extra
money oh we're going to do two we're
going to do two for him okay yeah all
right I'll take a black arm Mone choice
so that's our choice is what he saying
huh yeah yeah yeah okay U so we either
do a Wayland one or we'll do a logo one
how would you like a whan utani one with
a little damn like from Alien one and
it'll say 13:00 on the
back yeah we do that one too or like I
said you can have a logo one too if you
want yeah whatever the one nobody's
neither one of us is wearing the logo
one today I think I wor the logo shirt
yesterday actually did I I don't know
it's probably in the Today's
Show is about a very interesting case I
saw this [__] happen on television I've
been wanting to do this one for a while
I didn't realize that this had happened
so long ago like when I first started
reaching because remember we watched
there's a um documentary on Netflix
called Evil Genius which is a four-part
documentary series that's about this
case and I didn't realize how long ago
it was this [__] happened in 2003 yeah
holy crap that was yeah I remember it
like yesterday yeah because it kind of
happened live on TV yeah it happened
live on TV somebody commented earlier
though that the that when the bomb went
off it was kind of underwhelming because
they were hoping the guys had would blow
off yeah it didn't though no it was
something called a hot shot which is
basically a damn shotgun cartridge up
against pressed up against the back head
it was and it was up here like where the
damage was that's what killed him it
went into his chest it didn't blow his
head off I was working at the shop at
the time and me and a guy got an
argument over this [__] I was saying
man they had a damn bomb around that
guy's neck and and they were like yeah
but he's a criminal he robbed a bank and
I said you'd rob a bank too if [__]
put because he still needs to be locked
up just I was just like what kind of
[__] is this like a did but you know
what it turned out yeah he was a special
kind of [__] as it turned out maybe
he was right but we'll get into that
well I'm not sure about that like I'm
not so sure that he knew he might have
known about the plot but I'm not sure
that he that he knew that it was going
to be a live bomb or that it was going
to be you know what I mean there I don't
think they've ever really resolved that
spoiler alert like whether the guy
actually knew what was going to happen
or whether the bomb you know whether
they forc him with a bomb on or whatever
so it's like that was something that is
still like kind of open the air that was
a weird time too the early 2000s the
world was still kind of the old world at
that point it was still kind of sane too
social media had not [__] up
everybody's Minds yet you they had
internet but it was a lot like 90s
internet and and and and cable
television still kind of dominated it
was a different time weird was it I
don't even remember any I have a weird
thing where it's like I remember [__]
that happened like when I was a kid and
like in the 80s and 90s and [__] but
it's like I don't know after a certain
point it almost seemed like it happened
to somebody else and honestly after
about 1996 or so I'm just I I don't
really remember much of that's [__]
ridiculous that's [__] ridiculous I
remember like whatever I don't care I
remember it it's gone that era of the
internet was [__] kind of kind of
awesome it was the beginning of [__]
weird internet memes and weird you know
it was like the beginning of that you
know what I mean some of the [__] was
kind of [__] spooky and you didn't
you weren't really sure what was real
and what was you know what I mean and
what was true I mean were people really
eating each other were vs Real you
didn't you know what I mean yeah that
era was
weird yeah I guess it was like it it was
kind of like the World opening up to
people that didn't that had never like
thought about those types of things
before and then it's like now you were
kind of confronted with all confronted
with it's weird because it's it how
quickly it happened that now everything
is just like a big [__] yawn like
everybody's seen everything saying
everybody's like everybody's like yeah
yeah there's a channel I love it's
called Wang w h a n g with a exclamation
point he's got kind of like a Korean
American guy I think he's Korean got
long hair he looks like he likes metal
and [__] he's got a real cool [__]
setup and part of his show is to talk
about internet phenomena of that era and
if you guys ever want to check out Wang
go check out Wang I think it's w a w w
ha n g or w a a n g with an exclamation
point it's one of the two it's been a
while he's in my he's just in my [__]
list so this Tom loves Wang yeah Tom
love Wang I like that [__]
trying to be trying to be kinky on okay
but that's I really recommend that
channel you he talks about that era of
the internet a lot and like [__]
gamer [__] that was going on at that
time and [__] Mysteries mysteries on
the internet Dan thank you very much
Dan
did you want anything
okay all
right all right one of our Big Spenders
yeah a patron as well yeah I believe so
uh I don't think we had any particular
shout outs like I I don't think we had
any new patrons this week or any big
like uh PayPal donations or anything
like that I did want to remind everybody
that starting at the end of August uh
beginning of September right around
there uh patrons at all tiers are are
going to be able to start participating
in weekly polls you're going to be able
to pick what the next topic and what the
next movie retrospective is going to be
I'm going to have five options and you
can vote on which one you want to do and
like I said if nobody votes we'll just
do whatever the hell we want to do like
we were doing up until now also um
starting on the last Monday in August
which I think is the 31st maybe I can't
really see my calendar back there uh I'm
going to start putting up weekly horror
book reviews so uh hopefully you guys
that are into like horror fiction and
[__] like that will enjoy those I'm just
doing those on my own because Tom
doesn't read yeah not anymore I used
to I you know what I used to read a lot
more than I do I used every three weeks
I used to have a ritual I used to go to
the library this was when I used still
live in the Daytona and I used to go to
the library in Orman Beach and I would
check out a humongous like stack because
I read really fast so I so I would check
out a humongous stack of books and I
would read all of them like over the
three weeks usually before then and I
would have to take them back and um so I
would read like probably 20 30 books a
month easily um but you know since I've
been so busy like lately that I haven't
really had a chance to do that and it
was kind of bumming me out and I've kind
of got into all these other like book
channels like Jordine reads and uh you
know shades of orange and stuff like
that like these uh you know these ladies
that uh you know review horror books and
I've kind of got into those so I was
like man I really need to [__] get
back into reading horror fiction and
again I've gotten so behind so I went to
Amazon and I just bought like a whole
[__] pile it's back there a whole
pile of new horror novels that were
recommended by various channels and
stuff and I said I'm going to read all
these [__] and I'm going to review
every single one of them everybody
there's people in the comment section
talking about how cool Wang
is and it's not with a h it's it's just
w a n g I don't think it has exclamation
point I'm not sure Z Zach's going on
about how hot he is
see I've only seen him like randomly
like when I've like just walked through
the bedroom and seen him on the TV he he
looks like a pretty attractive Shir yeah
he's got long black hair Korean I think
he's a Korean guy or a Mongolian type of
guy with a mustache and a little goatee
he looks like he looks like what a
member of that damn Mongolian heavy
metal band oh yeah that's what he looks
like to me all right I forgot the name
of that band but that was a [__] good
band oh oh it's called The Who hu the
who really good Mongol and [__] metal
excellent no we're not that the who no
the other the who it's spelled
completely
different yeah oh um somebody wants to
update the update on the uh Golden State
killer he um pleaded guilty to all
charges and there's also some video of
this [__] CU that there was like a big
deal about how they kept like Wheeling
him into the [__] courtroom in a a
wheelchair like oh look he's just a
frail old man blah blah blah yeah well
they have like [__] footage from his
cell where he's just walking around and
[__] like a normal person which we
suspected all along they're just trying
to make him look like oh look how sad
and pathetic I am because all me yeah
[__] you [__] you he's just trying to
avoid the death penalty well they just
gave him life in prison yeah well I knew
that but I mean at least at least he
pleaded guilty so nobody had to go
through this big long [__] did they
make him do a confession or statement or
he just get [__] I'm guilty byebye I
think basically it was just like yeah
I'm guilty because I mean he's old
anyway so it's like it's not like yeah
but you know I got to say at least at
least my boy [__] went up there and
and and he expounded on his crimes you
know [__] you know what I'm talking
about weirdly you know talked about how
upset everyone was about it well you
know well you know of course you know
she was very upet I told her I was going
to kill her and of course she got very
upset so imagine that I gave her a
little tissue to so she could you know
get herself settled down
and you know I felt bad for
her What's creepy is just like that's
not exaggerated that's exactly how he
comes across I got to kill a [__] and
that's you know that's just how it yeah
have sexual problems and you have to
sexual problem I have to bind torture
and kill and you're just like yeah you
happen to be here and I just have to
like do it well Jenny you know
yeah do I have to go get Dennis you do
you do have to get Dennis I mean this is
a true crime show it's not like you know
a serial killer or anything but it's
like it is true crime so yeah you do
have to get Dennis go get Dennis yeah
here's Dennis with his little bobbling
head well Jenny you know mhm a man can't
deny who he is he's got the X Factor it
just kind of takes over you know yeah
he's a minor
yeah I look like a mortal
man but it's just an
illusion deep down I'm a
Minotaur can't you see my horn
oh my God I'm just going to leave
Dennis's [__] head poke it right
there yeah would it would it just go
around yeah I'm going go over here next
to you I I don't know I don't know I'm
I'm not comfortable you being that close
Den don't let me stand in between you
two even even though
you're I did tell you that Tom was an
[__] you did not today but you have
told me I'll I'll take that under
advisement not even a fraction of the
man I am not even a fraction he lacks
discipline lacks all kinds of displ okay
yeah when's the last time he's been a
[Laughter]
church he's not right with Jesus Dennis
spends a lot of time in church dragging
victims there telling them up taking
pictures of with his little [__]
panty hose and his gers on yeah trying
to bury himself with a girl mask on his
face he thinks he's an anime
character yeah if he even knew what
anime he seems a little square to know
what anime is I mean you know I'm just
saying I think he had a little Ane mask
on didn't he and that photographs that
he took himself when he was down that I
thought you know what it's weird it's
like I can't remember I'm just
remembering the picture like offand to
me it looked like that one that was in
Alice Sweet Alice like that one that
kind of looks like a face except it's
clear like so it looks like your face
but not your face which is like super
unsettling I'm just saying yeah I think
her name is il el Elsa Lansdale she's
saying she wants a shirt that says
visibly
upet you know what I you know would be
funny it's like it well I guess it's in
poor taste but it would still be pretty
funny like to put a a shirt like with
Dennis Raider's face on it and then
underneath it just said she was visibly
upset
yeah oh [__] mango Badgers in what's up
mango we were get I hope you didn't miss
[__] Dennis Dennis was here man
briefly yeah look he's got a little
knife and a cross I keep forgetting he
has a little cross in one hand I was
channeling Dennis yeah it'll it might
happen again like some point it could
happen you know what's really weird when
you were holding Dennis would have loved
this case probably yeah this is some
[__] Dennis would be into this is some
yeah this is some [__] they would have
gone to Dennis's cell and say Dennis
could you help us with this case oh of
course I can figure this out make feel
important yeah this is some weird ass
[__] it's like I rewatched like we had
watched the um the Evil Genius the
Netflix series we watched it like a long
time ago and then I just rewatched it
yesterday like in preparation for this
show and I had forgotten how [__]
labyrinthine this [__] case is
because it just seems like it's weird
enough that oh this dude just walks in
this bank with a [__] bomb strap to
his neck and hey I'm just a pizza
delivery guy and some people like put
this [__] on my neck or whatever and
then his head bleow up or whatever but
then like the more that they
investigated it it was just like there's
like other dead bodies involved there's
like all these other people involved
there's hoarders there's everything some
of this [__] something for everybody
some of this [__] verges on serial
killer type
stuff and like Clan cult type stuff I'm
saying Clan not like you know the
[__] KKK Clan we're just talking
about like [__] Mafia kind of weird
[__] in a way you'll see yeah this is a
weird [__] case family crime gangs
kind of sort of sort of and like I said
I'm I kind of suspect allegedly that
that woman that was either The
Mastermind or for sure like was in on it
I don't know if she was The Mastermind
if the other guy was The Mastermind but
um she was legit crazy also maybe a
serial killer yeah before we get off
into this case I want I want to
crowdsource some knowledge from you
[__] there was a case that I saw
we're trying to find it because we want
to do a show on it oh yeah okay okay
we'll see if somebody knows what he's
talking about cuz I I Googled it and I
like briefly and I couldn't find
anything about it this is back in the
late 80s I think maybe early 90s and it
was on Unsolved Mysteries on Unsolved
Myster the old one the classic Unsolved
Mysteries with Robert Stack you
know some dude turned up
dead and I don't remember how he died I
thought he might have been
shot but when they tried to figure out
who this guy was he had some kind of a
an ID on him that led him back to his
house led the investigators back to his
house and at that house he had a whole
bunch of other IDs and they all checked
out as being like real fake IDs in other
words they were expensive fake IDs with
passports and all kinds of stuff that
could stand up to
scrutiny some of this I think has
something to do with European
aristocracy and royalty maybe like from
Spain
or Portugal or something it's been a
long time I mean I remember it from back
in the time he seemed to have a whole
bunch of stuff
that he had a whole bunch of multiple
houses and a lot of money and envelopes
we're talking about hundreds of
thousands of dollars you know all over
the place stashed in all these different
houses in different forms of
currency and one of the things he had
was a Walter PPK and a [__] sound
suppressor like straight out of James
Bond and I don't think they ever really
figured out who this dude was he was
just a whole bunch of f really good fake
IDs yeah and he could he he couldn't
have been all them people and so
probably he was a spy or somebody that
he was either a spy or somebody who was
fantasizing that he was a spy he was
cosplaying as yeah but he had all this
money yeah
and I can't remember that any names or
anything that's just the situation we're
trying to find this case to see what
happened with it and maybe make a show
out of it cuz when you told me about it
I said that sounds like isll woman who
we did a show about and Summerton man
who we also did a show about I think we
did like them both on the same show that
was a long time ago that might have been
like the second or third episode we ever
did so it did sound like some spy [__]
um but then I was like I don't know I
was like I kept looking through the [__]
and it's like I found some cases kind of
like that but the most famous one that
kept coming up I think it happened in
Ireland I can't remember the dude's name
but um didn't have like a whole bunch of
identities he just had like one or two
different identities and they found him
like murdered I think they eventually
figured out who he really was if I
remember correctly this guy that he I
think he was found dead in Europe but
some of these houses were all over
Europe and I think maybe some of them
were in the United
States I just it's just been a long time
and maybe I'm not remembering it
correctly but I do remember that he had
a silenced
Walther and he pistol and they didn't
know who this guy was but they did know
they did know dudes who knew him yeah
they knew him under different Alias
aliases sure and they weren't sure what
the real one was Lou Hernandez says
maybe it was the case of Don Kemp I'll
have to look that up let me write that
down because I couldn't find anything
but I only looked at like three or four
pages of Google so thanks
Joe um you know thank you we just sent
you a shirt yesterday okay yeah it
mailed out so it'll probably get there
in a day or two went to the uh what you
call it what do you call that place the
post office we just went to the post
office yesterday okay so we got we got a
lead we got at least one lead yeah yeah
if you you guys remember you know and if
you're listening to this after the
show's recorded you could put it in the
comments
section but I'd like to pick that case
back up and see what the deal was with
that yeah cuz that sounded really
interesting like but one like happy
thing was that while I was researching
that I did come up with like a couple of
other cool ideas for other shows so I
wrote those down as well all right just
whatever while I kind of went down the
rabbit hole of like looking for that and
I couldn't find it and then I was like
on Unsolved Mysteries Wiki and like all
this other kind ofit but I thought of
that [__] the other day and I was I was
like man I wonder if they ever figured
out who that dude was and I was trying
to remember all the details of it yeah
so we could find it but I couldn't find
it somebody says that it's what Don Kemp
Don Kemp yeah you should look that's Lou
Hernandez that said that you should look
that up I mean I'll look it up I wrote
it down look it up okay I wrote it down
I can't really look it up right now I'm
L my place yeah you kind of been in the
middle of sh I don't I don't want to
mess anything up over here did the Dom
Camp case have anything to do with the
Walther PPK and a silencer bunch of
safes you had a bunch of safes in a
bunch of houses it took them a while to
crack all those safes and to get in
there and there some of them had like
envelopes with like [__] hundreds of
thousands of dollars in different kinds
of currency yeah and that pistol and he
had passports from a bunch of different
um countries I even think he had some
like fake military style ident IDs like
fake Navy IDs like he was a naval
officer in one of his [__]
identifications or at least an ex-naval
officer or something it was weird they
didn't know who the guy was it reminded
me a little bit too of um Frank abing
nail but he didn't kill anybody but he
was just like a really good uh con man
like he pretended to be like an ER
doctor he PR to be an airline pilot he
pretended to be all kind of the [__] and
he didn't get caught for like a really
long time they made a movie about him
called Catch Me If You Can with Tom from
what I remember he this guy was from
this is just memory and it was a long
time ago he was found dead shot I think
and they were investigating how he died
it was a mysterious death but they
weren't sure if it was a suicide made
look like a murder or what yeah like I
said it reminded me a little bit of isll
woman like that woman they found up in
Norway back in the day and like she'd
been burned to death and then she had
like eight different passports and all
this other kind of [__] was it a Hawaii
ID named mcloven mlov that sounds yeah
that's from like [__] what the hell
is that movie called I can't remember
what it's I don't
know I'm not drunk I swear I just can't
remember what it is mck Lovin was that
skinny little kid just chasing them big
old [__] five black
girls isn't that this skinny little
white kid with the with the little white
man afro yeah yeah little white I don't
remember what it was some kind of movie
was a character movie yeah it's a yeah
it's a movie McLovin yeah um Dan says
I'd say Don Kemp is not the cas you're
looking
for but yeah super bad thank you that's
of the movie yeah why I don't know why I
couldn't remember that it was I was like
it's one word
it's all right so are we gonna start
talking about go start all right go and
start the
show yeah now that we're like half an
hour in no 40 minutes in we're 40
minutes
in that's okay that's that's what people
expect you know yep all right so uh
we're talking about the collar bomb
Heist also known as the pizza bomber
case so August 28th
2003 this dude who's a pizza delivery
man which they will find out later his
name is Brian Wells about 2:30 in the
afternoon he walks into a PNC Bank in
Erie
Pennsylvania now he's carrying a cane
which actually they found out later was
a gun shitty ass shotgun yeah if you
look at it you go that's not a cane I've
seen it it yeah only from a distance
does that look like a cane it's short
it's not like long enough it was pretty
long from what I remember just that it
had you could tell that it had a damn
trigger on it and a [__] breach yeah
just single shot shotgun it looked like
it was made out of damn plumbing pipe
and a bunch of conduit and [__] I mean
they did say later that it would have
worked oh yeah it would have worked it
would have worked sure it's just that it
was it was a very feeble attempt at
hiding the fact that it was a [__]
shotgun yeah it wasn't real yeah you
could tell that it wasn't a g this
wasn't like like we said this wasn't
some like high you know Hightech James
Bond it was made in a garage you could
tell well yeah it probably was or was
made in like a Hoy
house like everything else in this yeah
easy to make a single shot shotgun so he
comes in the bank wearing a a guest
t-shirt like a white T-shirt with his
big weird bulge like right here I do
actually have a picture of this where is
it there it is that's what it looked
like yeah see the top of that cane it's
like the damn size of a [__] cart and
a cigarettes everyone's just looking at
him like what the [__] is that all about
I don't know you guys can't you guys
could hear that while that [__]
picture was up right we got that sorted
right uh hopefully I did yeah I set this
all up beforehand so hopefully I didn't
[__] it up too bad but yeah so he walks
in and he seems totally calm he goes up
to uh the one of the tellers he waited
in line for a little while which I
thought was kind of funny and then he
decided [__] this and then he goes up to
one of the tellers and he hands her a
note the note said Gather employees with
access codes to Vault and work fast to
fill a bag with
$250,000 you have only 15 minutes and
then he picks his shirt up like that and
there's the device strapped to his neck
now he says uh that it's a
bomb and uh so the teller is like okay
well we can't get into the vault in 15
minutes because I I don't know if most
bank robbers know but they usually have
rules about who can go in the vault and
it's like it takes all this you need all
these different people to [__] do it
and everything so the teller was like we
can't get into the vault in 15 minutes
we can only give you what's in the
drawers at the moment which happened to
be uh about
$8,700 so they put all of that cash into
a bag and they handed it to him now the
weird thing about this is that Brian
Wells at the time seemed to be acting
very casual like this wasn't like he had
a bomb strapped around his neck but he
wasn't acting like he had a bomb
strapped around his neck and you know
what I'm saying it's like he took the
time to like get a lollipop out of the
thing on the counter and he's just like
strolling out of the bank somebody said
it like Charlie Chaplain quote unquote
like just swinging the cane and Swinging
the bag with the cash in it like out of
the [__] bank right yeah fourth
drawer down made a good observation he
says that's a cane disguised as a
shotgun pretty
much now could you guys hear us talking
when that photograph was up we hopefully
they should too I mean the mic looked
like it was still audio mix here well I
think the only time the the reason why
that happened before was because I
forgot to duplicate the main screen okay
and then put the picture over it I just
put the picture in there so it just went
to picture with no sound okay thanks
Sandra thanks fly Griffin yeah they
heard us they heard us
yeah so he leaves the bank uh gets in
his car and drives off now he didn't
actually get all that far far before he
got
caught uh about 15 minutes after the
bank
robbery uh they the authorities found
him he was standing outside of his car
which was a geom Metro uh in the in a
nearby parking lot which I think was
like a Pearl Vision Center or some kind
of Vision Center or something so he's
standing in the parking lot um so they
surround him they throw him on the
pavement and they cuff him now his story
was that he was out delivering pizza
and a whole uh group of black men had
come up and chained the bomb around his
neck at gunpoint like they do and force
him to rob it yeah like that happens all
the time those black dudes man they're
[__] great at [__] making bombs
and strapping them all the white dudes
and making them R it's just it happens
all it happens all the time I just can't
count the amount of times that's
happened to me yeah it's just they're
good at that well the weird thing about
this case is that they even had like you
know during the documentary and
everything like that that they even had
like all the FBI agents and [__] that
worked on the case they didn't believe
that not one bit well well no they
didn't but they were also like this is
pretty much the only case like this
that's ever happened they're like we're
not saying that people don't try to like
rob banks and [__] with you know bomb
like devices or [__] they say is a bomb
but they're like
99.999% of the time that's a fake yep
because why make a real one and like go
through all the time and risk of blowing
yourself up and [__] like that fake
bombs work just like work to act like
it's
if fake it's it seems Smarter with a
fake smar with a fake and a fake bomb if
you got caught you would not be facing
it wouldn't be exactly so it's like
there's really not a lot of reason to
use a real one there's not even a real
reason to use a real gun in a bank
robbery exactly that's what I'm saying
for the same reason they're instructed
not to resist if you just give them a
note saying that you have a gun they'll
give you the money and they'll give you
the money it's insured they don't care
and if you get caught pulling a note job
in the United United States the way the
law works out it's not armed robbery
it's bank robbery but it's not armed
yeah you'll get a lighter sent a because
you weren't actually like putting
anyone's life in danger and then you
could if you weren't a [__] then
here's another thing because we're
dealing with a [__] Criminal Justice
System that's depends on people who are
imperfect
okay if it was a note job and you're a
firsttime offender never been caught for
it you could give a sob story about how
desperate you were and wo was me this
and that yeah I need you you might get a
[__] really light sentence on that
first one well yeah if you were like
pitiful enough now when I say light
sentence really think I hav consider a
really light Sent I'm talking about in
the United States two three years as
opposed to years but that's a pretty
light sentence I mean if you ask me bank
robbery should should be about 10 years
you know that that that's about what
that should be I don't know well I mean
it has to be a stiff sentence or they do
it they go oh it's worth it I'm going to
rob it yeah it's just like in Most
states here in the United
States stealing a car is Grand Theft
Auto there are some states well if you
try to steal a car when a person's in it
it's considered car jacking they can
shoot you dead on a [__] spot it's a
[__] death because well that's
understandable because you're putting
that person in danger if a person above
the age of 18 steals a car in an average
State here and they steal it by you know
picking locks or or you know I mean by
aggravated means using a gun or whatever
near 15 years you know um if they break
in through the lock and [__] Jack the
car and Joy Ride Like That if you're
above the age of [__] 18 you're going
to first offender you're going to go two
three years for that but there are some
countries like in the UK you can steal a
car and they laugh at it they think oh
well you know you're supposed to steal
cars that just I've heard that they
steal cars for fun there they driv
around I don't know about nowadays but
back in the day that seemed like like I
mean the murder rate was pretty low like
the the rate for other [__] like
breaking and entering and [__] was
pretty low but car theft was like cuz
that was just like what you did and it
was usually like teenage boys they would
just like steal someone's car drive
around it at joy ride and then set it on
fire on some Hill somewhere yeah that
was just like a thing that you did and
everyone like nobody liked it but
everyone was just kind of like H the
United States doesn't boys will be boys
the United States doesn't play we have a
prison industry
complex which is kind of like the Soviet
Gulag system we got a huge number of
people incarcerated and they're making
money off of it they're making license
plates they're making stuff and
factories and [__] and the way they see
it is they say well we got two choices
you let this sucker Stay Free and he's
on the welfare system and we're actually
losing money we're losing tax money
keeping this guy free or we put him in
prison and make profit off of him so
where is the incentive it's prison
that's why why there's so many people in
prison for like [__] drug charges
and [__] okay and it's because in
general the system sees a an excess
population problem they see this as
interdicting population growth they see
it as profiting and it's just the way it
is this is uh kind of a Savage situation
and you look right now the United States
there's a lot of [__] problems all
right part of it is because of that
criminal justice system
I don't really put it on the cops per se
they're doing what they're told to do
I'd put a lot of it on the courts and
the
prisons and what they're doing they're
putting a lot of people in prison for
long periods of time for in some cases
victimless crimes really yeah for or
nonviolent [__] right a lot of this drug
[__] is [__] [__] that's what I
mean I just I don't yeah the concept of
illegal drugs is really is a New Concept
back in the 1800s early 1900s you could
take whatever drugs you wanted they
didn't give a [__] yeah and that's your
body your body yeah well I kind of
that's kind of how I feel about well I
mean as long as you're not going out and
affecting like I said it's like you can
drink as much as you want you can drink
yourself into stupefaction in your own
house if you want to now if you get out
in the street and start driving then
that is everyone else's problem that's a
different situation that's a different
situation that's still driving while
intoxicated you you should get slammed
for that right but it has to be kind
of there's a difference between a dude
who's had a few drinks but is driving
successfully and a dude who habitually
drinks himself into a stupid and [__]
wrecks there's a big difference cuz you
come out on a Saturday night everybody's
driving home drunk they're all driving
home drunk but most people can drive
pretty drunk they're driving pretty
sane I mean we it's true it's not to
scary and the cops know I mean and here
my advice to you I have worked with law
for companies that work for law
enforcement I know a lot of cops if a
cop pulls you over and you're [__]
drunk and he says have you had have you
been drinking tonight what do you tell
him yes yes you [__] lie to a cop
you're you're going to get locked up
don't deny you're G to get yeah I've
been Dr they know you're lying they know
you're [__] lying they're going to
blow you already you've been drinking
yes sir I have how much have you had to
drink three or four drinks from I
remember I'm I'm are you drunk yeah I'm
pretty drunk I'm driving good though I
got experience and a lot of times a lot
of times they can [__] work something
out depending on where you are and who
you are if they like you or not be
honest with the [__] cops cooperate
you remember one time now this was
before we went to the club like we were
going to the club so we hadn't drunk
anything we didn't pregame or nothing
yeah so it's me you and maybe Kaylee
yeah Kay and they tore the car apart
yeah they pulled us over for what why
did they pull us over I don't even
remember we had a head reason we had a
headlight out oh was it was a reason
okay they used that as an excuse to
um pull us over cuz we looked like
weirdos yeah we we were Goths so I think
I think we were going out I think the
cops were [__] flirting with Kaylee
we're looking at Kaylee too maybe they
just wanted they searched my car they
searched and searched and searched they
went all through there they were looking
for drugs like all through my trunk and
everything I'm like cuz they were like
well can we search your car I'm like hey
knock yourself out I don't have anything
better than go out on a weekend do not
carry [__] drugs well we didn't have
any car we didn't have any drugs we
didn't have any booze we didn't have
anything we're so boring don't carry
drugs and don't carry [__] booze in
your [__] car I mean you know that's
all I got to do I never have drugs or
booze in my car follow the [__] rules
so I was just like I I don't know I I
was pissed because I was just kind of
like well I'd like to get to the club in
like a timely fashion but I was like if
the cops want to waste their time
[__] turning my car over and find
nothing yep okay go ahead I just stood
there on the side of the road and looked
at him like here's another time here's
another stupid thing I watch all these
[__] videos of these guys getting
killed for resisant arrests on minor
[__]
charges I'm looking at this and I'm
going wait a minute hold on this is a
DUI or something pretty minor why is
this guy [__] resist an arrest you
know what I mean he's going to go to
jail he's going to bond out in [__]
about 12 hours you know he can't do 12
hours why is he resisting well he must
be running from a bigger charge May
they're not
but that's what you start thinking you
go he must have committed a murder he
must be wanting for other things why is
he resisting so hard on a minor charge
boils down to some people just don't
have any [__] sense they're stupid
all right don't resist the [__] cops
all they're going to do is just take you
to jail and you're going to bond out a
few hours later if you can't bond out
you're probably out in a few days it
ain't gonna make a difference if you're
white yeah no if you're black too it
won't make a difference it won't make a
difference or they might just shoot you
depends on the no I've watched all those
shootings I there's a there's a channel
called police activity Glenn says don't
they need probable cause to search a car
no they don't um if they ask you and you
say it's okay yeah then they can and I
didn't have anything in my car so I told
them it's like hey if you guys want to
waste your [__] time searching my car
then go right ahead there's a bunch of
bunch of misconceptions a lot of it
depends on on the state that you're in
each State's going to have you know
United States has 50 [__] States all
right each one's like a different
country uh for the most part they can
search you because they want to they
just can if you're in
car um they can't come in your house
they have to have a warrant but they can
search your car uh if you say no they'll
just get a warrant and they'll search
your car so you might as well just say
yeah search it okay well like I said I
don't have anything in there so and they
don't have to read you your rights
that's another myth they can just arrest
you you have to read me right no they
[__] don't that's something off a TV
there's no they don't have to mirandize
you yeah they can just arrest your ass
and and they don't have to arrest you
that's another thing is they can just
hold you which is different that's
called detainment and do it up to a
certain number 24 hours 48 hours what is
it and a lot of dudes start freaking out
before they're even arrested they're
freaking out when they're being detained
and and I'm watching these videos
they're like dude chill the [__] out you
haven't been arrested yet you're being
detained and they're judging whether or
not they're going to arrest this dude
based on how he's acting during
detainment if you start getting ancy you
start freaking out during detainment
you're G to get
arrested if you chill out during
detainment and [__] cooperate joke
around with the cops and you don't
really have anything to they're going to
get they're going to get bored like a
cat with a mouse that isn't struggling
they just let it go a lot of times
depends on what the charge is what says
what do you do when they plant something
well then you're hosed you're hosed
anyway Sandra says is it not allowed to
have alcohol in your car in the USA you
can as long as the um container is
closed you can't have an open container
in your car depended on the state
Louisiana you could drink while driving
for a long long time I think they
finally sorted that out in the '90s
which that was some that was a weird
Time Elsa says what if you have an open
bottle but it's in the trunk yeah you
yeah I think you can do that that's all
right yeah I mean as long as it's not
open container like in the car that
looks like you're [__] drinking it
right if shit's in the trunk because
I've driven with booze in the trunk
before like we were going to a concert
and we were going to pregame when we got
there in the parking lot so I had
Whiskey in the trunk Most states will
not allow you to have a Firearms within
Arms Reach of operating a motor vehicle
unless you have a concealed carry permit
or concealed weapon then you can have it
within Arms Reach some states allow it
yeah some states allow it because they
uh they've they've legally uh they've
legally determined that a car is an
extension of the home okay so you being
in your car is a lot like being in your
home in your home and I don't know which
states that were and I don't know if
it's still like that but from what I
remember some states were like that many
states
allow you to use lethal Force if someone
attempts to enter into your vehicle yeah
castle doctor whatever they call that's
the same as breaking and entering into a
person's house they have that in Florida
too yeah in Florida if a person touches
your car door or hits your window that
person can pull out a [__] pistol and
open
fire because yeah because you think that
like oh they're trying to get because
it's an attempted carjacking or it's an
attemp [__] home invasion so it's
like castle doctor Dan says all this
talk of alcohol made me get a
jack yeah o I love Jack and Coke I don't
have any Jack well I have some actually
it's not Jack is it it's uh what's the
other one Jim Beam Apple it's Jim Beam
Apple which is actually pretty good it
is pretty good yeah I mean you know I
know a lot of people would be like ew no
pretty yeah I like it it's a good
sipping whiskey well and I like to mix
it with apple juice for like a full-on
apple experience but it's good just on
the Rocks too you could just drink that
[__] on the Rocks it's it's like a
whiskey with an apple Lor mixed in with
it do you remember when we went to what
show did we go to it might have been
Evan essence or psychic Furs or
something I can't really remember we
went to um [__] Downtown Disney yeah
and uh we pregamed big time we had like
a big huge thing of I think it was Jack
Daniels in my trunk and we stopped and
got big gulps and poured the jack in the
big gulps while we were waiting in line
I'm pretty sure that was Evan Essence
yeah I think CU remember I bought you
tickets to that for your birthday one
year and look we were waiting outside
the House of Blues like with these big
gulps and everybody's like oh we just
have big gulps but it was like half
whiskey yeah somebody said that that
dude in Seattle wouldn't have been
pulled out of his car if he was armed
that's right there's a bunch of
[__] like these crowds of people these
BLM people getting in front of moving
traffic to stop the car that only seem
seems to work in those particular areas
cuz whoever's doing that has somehow
determined in within the state laws
there that that isn't attempted
carjacking if you did that in
Florida that might be considered
attempted carjacking if you considered
that crowd to be a threat to your life
which sometimes they're they're getting
in front of that crowd and then shooting
into that car or pulling that person out
of the car in a state like Florida if a
crowd of people tried to get in front of
a car or a truck to stop it here they'd
floor it run out run over them all
that's why they're not doing it thank
you Dom the bomb and that's how it would
go in
Louisiana Louisiana's [__] crazy I
lived there for [__] about six
years if you tried to [__] jump into
a bunch of if a bunch of [__]
protesters jumped in front of a car in
Louisiana your average cinjun would
[__] floor it go through the whole
crowd then they'd back up to hit them
again and then they'd go that's how
cinjun are that's not good though
they're [__] nuts they're [__]
nuts they would take that [__]
personally but you shouldn't cuz it's
not that's just how they are I know it's
a cultural difference well they're not
that's childlike though that's child
that's cinjun that's cinjun okay they
would go okay all right Sandra said now
she's from Germany yeah she says so a
passenger who is not driving can't drink
in the car even if the driver is sober
right no open containers in C you can't
have open containers so yeah even if the
driver is not drinking you will get if
the passenger is drinking you will get
in trouble yeah yes you will no but
which is kind of dumb but you know all
that all those techniques that those
protesters are using those are directed
by professional protesters all those
tactics that they're doing are being
directed uh by people that understand
the state laws and the cultures that's
why it's not happening in certain other
places because there are other states
where people would would not react that
same
way yeah we're all have equal access to
the law we're not all equal okay each
one of these states has different
cultures and different ways of looking
at things and uh some of these [__]
states in the South they they just they
don't they don't see things that way
they're going to be like this is an
attempted carjacking they're trying to
kill me uh [__] these people I'm GNA
[__] go down I'm gonna die you know
what I mean they go into a
kamakazi attack mode and that's why they
don't do it there they do that up north
where they can get away with it there
are certain neighborhoods where you
can't do [__] like that yeah there are
places here in Orlando there are
neighborhoods here in Orlando where
you're taking your life into your own
hands going there all right you couldn't
pull any of that [__] there but okay go
ahead um somebody asked to like I forgot
now because I was trying to like [__]
yeah somebody she asked about other uh
drinking laws too she said uh you also
have strange laws with drinking outside
yeah alcoholics bottled yeah you can't
really I mean you can drink outside of a
bar like you can go like outside of a
bar on the patio or whatever
you can't just walk around drinking yeah
that's called public intoxication yeah
even if you're not drunk but if you're
walking around even when you're leaving
a club or a bar you can't take like the
alcoholic drink out of the main entrance
with you right you know what I mean they
don't even let you really take water
bottles out because they think that you
poured them the booze into the water
bottle anded to escape it came from an
era and that's actually very Southern
that concept is very
Southern it came from an era where they
were trying to clean up the South like
down in New Orleans and uh places like
Jackson Mississippi where the nighttime
in the
1800s was just filled with dudes walking
around at night
drunk usually with [__] pistols okay
so they were tried to keep that [__]
down to a minimum they wanted to keep
the drinking off of the streets like I
can understand that right like I said to
an extent it was another era when go
over with it because yes I understand
that people that are drunk there's a
whole bunch of drunk people walking
around the street that's not a good
situation because they'll be like fights
and and in the US it'll be like [__]
shooting and everything like that
because people will get upset and they
won't well they start [__] with each
other right exactly so I get that but I
don't know like in another
way but it's also situational and it's
it depends on the city ordinances and
the Times Like New Orleans during marra
the entire French Quarter is drinking in
the middle of the [__] Street it's a
parade and a festival drinking in the
middle of the [__] Street and getting
nude in the [__] Street middle of the
street and sometimes sex in the street
well that's a special situ it's like
Brazilian Carnival the Carnival in
Brazil was even bigger I loved Carnival
when I Liv there but it's it's not as
bad as it was uh New Orleans the cops
have really cleaned up the French cour
order they don't allow it to get as
crazy as it was in the ' 80s and the 70s
in the 70s and the ' 80s it was really
[__] crazy I mean I don't have a
problem with people doing anything in
the street even like [__] in the
street as long as it's not like in front
of little kids but the problem is the
problem is is that Marty Gro started to
[__] sometimes you started seeing
little kids in Marty Gro that was a
problem yeah I get that I mean I'm not
one of those like oh think of the
children type of people but yeah you can
see how it would be like awkward to have
to explain to your kids hey Mommy what
are those two doing yeah or what are
those five people doing right
yeah they're having a good time honey
let's go it's really you know the United
States you know people think that
[__] everything's falling apart and
it's all decadent and [__] it's not
really in a way um it was crazier in the
70s and the 80s it's just that people
didn't know that's what I mean I feel
like like people like get all [__]
freaked out about [__] nowadays but it's
like the' 60s the 70s the early ' 80s
way worse it's worse it way worse way
worse and and not always in a good way
there was a lot more violent a lot then
and it was but the average person didn't
know because there was no social media
and there was no internet so when
something would happen it was isolated
to that area and just the witnesses the
general public didn't even know that
that [__] happened yeah I mean I I feel
like the only reason that people freak
out nowadays is because you just hear
about it more like back then it happened
a lot more yeah but you just didn't hear
about it and like I said it was the same
thing I you know I wrote about True
Crime from like the [__] beginning of
like the 20th century horrible horrible
[__] happened back then and people
didn't get caught and [__] but nobody
heard about it really it's like it
wasn't all over like the [__] world
in two minutes so I feel like people had
more of a sense of oh well they didn't
hear about it in their little town so
everything must be okay and here's
another thing that's weird you know we
talk about [__] the child Island Man and
[__] estein and all these [__]
[__] that [__] Billy boy was doing
with these girls in their [__] late
teens and early 20s and sometimes mid
teens 16
17 you look at that now in the text in
in modern context and that's some
[__] bizarre
[__] but that was real kind of common
[__] that was going on in the 60s and
70s these older guys with these young
women you know that was just they just
did
that generation was into that and I
remember too like a lot of cities like
New York City in the 70s and 80s was not
safe there were like parts of it you
couldn't go and you would get like
[__] mugged or murdered or whatever
and it's like when I went there in the
90s and 2000s it's like there were some
neighborhoods where said it's kind of
sketchy but it wasn't like anything like
it was back in those old days nothing
like that yeah what's what was strange
about the child Island man was uh the
fact that these are very wealthy rich
men on it this island that's kind of
like the ancient island of Capri and
Emperor [__] what was his name
Emperor tiberious and [__] you know what
I mean I think that's what his name was
uh
[__] and maybe these girls are kind
of borderline sex slaves or are they
underage prostitutes what is this so
this is [__] really freaking out the
average person and kind of rightly so
but why wouldn't it be like that the
[__] ruling classes have always been
pretty [__] degenerate and um well
because they can be they can be bad
behavior is at the very opposite ends of
the spectrum at the very poor it's
cockroaches and the very rich it's
[__] sharks it's extreme Behavior
it's not this middle of the road middle
class sanity people have to just [__]
work for a living and be good or you go
get punished these people don't have
don't ever get punished they either own
the system or they can evade the system
on either spectrum and you know what I
mean it's just
of course they're going to be
degenerate you know well if there are no
consequences there's no consequences for
them Behavior then sure I mean not
everyone's going to be like that because
some people do actually have like
consciences and principles and stuff but
the ones that don't and will rise to the
top uh so you're going to have a ruling
class no matter what country you're in
because it was like that in Brazil too
you know I went to a school gradu water
to S Pao which is a real expensive
Brazilian [__] private school and the
kids of the [__] presidents and the
[__] would be king of Brazil and the
[__] SE celebrities and [__] it's a
little small American International
School you know because my mother was in
the state department I went there and
you know it had [__] armed guards and
[__] you know you can look at it up on
the internet there's [__] videos
[__] fantastic videos of how they
educate people it it's a real good
education you know it's IB International
B
Gloria all those kids were [__] wild
a lot of them were doing [__] drugs
and cocaine and [__] and well yeah like
I said by time they could do whatever
they want they whatever they [__]
want the teachers were [__] terrified
of them the teachers were terrified of
them cuz their parents were kind of like
the equivalent of like Saddam Hussein
they were the former military well and
teachers were just trying to do a job
it's like I'm going to get fired if I
[__] no killed too much or kill
killed well they were scared of them
because Brazil was coming out of a
[__] military dictatorship and these
were the [__] kids of the former
military dictators of Brazil and the new
people in the Senate and [__] they were
like Saddam you C and Brazil was kind of
like run by run by cartels they were
kind of like drug cartels like something
you got of
Colombia well I was like I thought they
were just [__] spoil rotten you know
[__]
indisciplined half of them just [__] you
know the girls were [__] super super
[__] just I can't even F I'm getting
kind too jump to describe it you know
but uh real [__] arrogant and real um
Mighty you know anyway uh they were like
royalty and they owned almost all of
Brazil's wealth you know how [__]
wealth tends to gravitate towards the
very very top well they got there
because they were just [__] ruthless
and it's like genetic and it's like
passed down to their children they kind
of stayed in an infantile State even as
they grew
up um man it was [__] wild been a
long time since I thought about that
But as time went on I realized you know
I thought the United States was [__]
kind of uh uh immune to that but no as
time went on no they were ruled by the
exact same kind of people they they just
they were just shielded by the the lack
of Internet you know but now that the
internet's around everybody knows who
they are that's why they're scared yeah
and most of them have left the country
they they they live overseas offshore
they kind of run the United States by
remote control because bandwidth and
computers allow them to do do it but a
lot of them don't really live here
anymore we they probably get [__]
just in case something goes they all
move they all move to uh uh what's that
little bitt at New Zealand they live in
New Zealand and they they're on vacation
over in Europe and then down all the
kiwis are like get the [__] off my yeah
C they have evidently they all have
houses down there but it's not just
America the European oligarchs kind of
live there too it's that's all the same
click trying to escape the peons Y just
in case [__] goes wrong you can't eat
them we can't come after them with
pitchforks which that might happen we'll
see I'm all right with that
Pitchfork so we were talking about the
collar bomb case yeah I'm getting
sidetracked but they love it when we get
sided before we went off on this well
[__] man my drink's almost empty we
might you know what I I noticed when you
held up your drink to the camera it
looked like green and then I looked at
it in real life and it doesn't look like
that but on the camera it looked really
green I don't know if it looks green to
you you guys but it does so yeah so they
catch this guy like 15 minutes after the
[__] bank heist right Brian Wells so
he tells them it's like oh a bunch of
black guys jumped on me and like put
this [__] bomb on my neck like at
gunpoint um so he tells them it's going
to go off I'm not lying and he starts
getting like more and more freaked out
about it so the cops as they have to do
they call the bomb squad now there
wasn't a bomb squad like super close
close
by so basically they put him they sat
him by a [__] police car um kind of
far enough away from it where if the
bomb went off it wouldn't like hurt
anybody else so they just kind of like
stood behind their cars and like aimed
their guns at them which I think I have
a picture of I do indeed there it is so
they just kind of sat there and looked
at him and he started getting like more
and more kind of freaked out like hey
you guys going to like try to get this
off or anything they're like yeah yeah
the bomb squad's coming and whatever so
three minutes before the bomb squad
arrived the [__] start it goes beep beep
beep beep beep beep beep beep and the
guy's eyes get really big and blam it
[__] went off now it didn't like
somebody mentioned earlier it didn't
blow his head off um because most the
the bulk of the bomb it was like it was
essentially a pipe bomb like inside of a
this big box type of thing and it was
like on his chest so basically what it
did was when it went off it like blew a
hole into his chest which is what killed
him now when the bomb squad arrived he
was actually still alive but he was just
like you know breathing really raggedly
and stuff and he died like very shortly
after they arrived um
so the the thing about this is that like
I said this poor guy and I feel like for
four years before they really even knew
what the [__] was going on and like how
intricate this [__] cluster [__] of a
plan was this guy was seen as the victim
which I still think he was to a large
extent I mean I'm not saying that he
didn't know about the plot and all this
other kind of [__] but I don't think
that he
actually I mean my opinion being I don't
think he actually consented to hey let's
put a live bomb around my neck you know
what I mean I don't think either he
thought it was fake or he was forced to
do it or something like that I don't
think that he
knew entirely like what the [__]
entailed you know what I'm saying so I
don't think he was entirely Innocent but
I don't think that he was like in on all
the [__] either like I don't think he
agreed to what ended up happening to him
you know what I'm saying so they showed
like the the bomb went off like on live
TV which was
horrifying the shitty thing was that one
of the last things this poor guy said
like before the [__] bomb went off
was did you call my boss he was a afraid
that he was going to lose his job at the
pizza delivery place because of these
Shenanigans and that was one of the last
things that he thought of isn't that sad
you're like worrying about your [__]
pizza and a liery job yeah people are
asking what I'm drinking I'm drinking
Rockstar and [__] Silver
Tequila they're going yeah time to drink
tequila
[Music]
yeah I can't drink tequ woo that's
strong God damn oh really it is yeah
yeah I guess it was that's all right
I'll I'll sip it slowly hopefully I have
I've only got like three paragraphs
could be that I didn't really stir that
too well before I dropped which go it's
all right yeah Dan says totally agree it
wasn't like he was the brightest guy in
the world he wasn't and that's what was
really sad like I kind of I'll kind of
get into it later but um that friend of
his or that uh sex worker that he went
to all the time Jessica hoopsick she
actually said well I introduced him to
these crazy people that put this plan
together as like someone that was easily
manipulated because he wasn't all that
bright D and she's not like the most
credible witness but in a way I do kind
of believe that like just from what I've
heard about that guy I don't think he
was like The Brightest Bulb is all I'm
saying and I don't think he really knew
what what the whole [__] entailed and he
didn't know he was going to get blown up
that day so yeah so he had sat there for
25 minutes and then the [__] [__]
went off and uh and it killed him so
bomb squad arrived 3 minutes after the
bomb had gone off so they go through the
cops start going through like all the
[__] in the car they find uh the cane
which was 2 feet long which was also a
shotgun like I said uh which actually
worked like a shotgun the bomb was
actually when they started um taking it
oh thank you Mark for the shipping a
this that's fine don't worry about it um
yeah so keep them flash bulbs rolling
people I love it when that [__] happens
he does I love it when that [__] happens
love you're going to be incoherent by
the time be get incoherent but I'll have
a I'll have a job to do when this is all
over have to make all these [__]
shirts yeah it it it doesn't take that
long no just make sure you get keep all
the orders straight I'll get them done I
try I try to keep everything straight we
need to come up with some new design I'm
the one that's got to keep everything
straight she's like the secretary
because if he doesn't because he can't
do it no I can't do that
sh someone got to do it I get like
stressed out about like having to just I
have fine she stresses herself out over
these little things she's a [__]
she's a master
organizer yeah but I'm I'm a master
organizer because I get stressed out
about [__] if I didn't get stressed out
about [__] I would never get anything
done probably right so it's like it
sucks having to be stressed out about
everything all the time but if I didn't
stress out about everything all the time
then I would never have [__] done and
have it done correctly [__] this [__]
started out as your business though you
know what I'm talking about it did and
it grew it grew from like from a small
seed it grew into a [__] Willow
tree it did yeah yeah like I said I do
get stressed out about it though you're
doing fine you got new books and all
kinds of [__] coming I know I got so
many projects I got like in the we got
to do we got to finish our cookbook I
got a whole I got a Halloween themed
game coming yeah I got a [__] I got
my next audio book coming which is one
of my older novels that I'm finally
doing an audio book okay um yeah so oh
the Edgar Allen Poe game that I'm made
which is an ed gr and po trivia game I
ordered a proof copy of it so as soon as
I get the proof copy if it looks okay
then I will put that up for sale as well
so I've got like some other games
too uh yeah bees nest says Brian Well's
family was mad because they had to cut
his head off to get the bomb off they
did um that's it's really [__] up
because in the documentary basically
they wanted the bomb obviously so they
could study it and rebuild and see like
who you know see if they could figure
out who had made it like you know uh
because of how it was put together so to
get the bomb intact they had to cut
Brian wells's Head off which means that
at the funeral they couldn't have like
an open casket obviously and it was like
weird because I'm watching the
documentary and like the guy like one of
the investigators was like well we you
know we had to decapitate him but we did
it with um with care yeah I was like ah
I mean I know they had to do it I know
they need the evidence like I get it Lou
say I'm back here getting Getting Faded
Tom's Getting Faded
Tom yeah you're right B you'll be all
right you're right I'm you've only had
one that that [__] there was like a
[__] quadr he's still on his first
drink that [__] was like a qu mean I had
to add ice I had to add ice to it is
like a huge yeah [__] artichoke jar
this [__] was like a [__] quadruple
it was like two
doubles yeah yeah I'm holding on though
you better yeah I'm [__] fine we're
only an hour and 20 minutes in I'm [__]
[__] fine man I'm doing good
he's Maria says I got I'm a [__] meat
head I could take this come
on it's all meat in there it's all just
meat
yeah yeah Maria says I got to go take
care of my elderly mom and walk my Dogo
all right Maria Mar you have a good one
you have a good one you can watch this
on put some earphones
on I know she's not listening through
her phone I understand you got to like
take
not everybody can do [__] on Saturday
nights like we can do yeah so they had
to cut his head off but yeah so uh so
the bomb they figured out it was like
okay so there was a metal collar which
was kind of like a big handcuff
essentially it worked the same as that
it had uh a three-digit combination lock
and then there was like a box which was
up against his chest that had two 6in
pipe bombs in
it um yeah so they found two kitchen
timers which are just just like Sunbeam
kitchen timers the bread company uh that
had the [__] that was going to it and it
also had like a lot of fake [__] in it
so it had like a lot of red herrings
like a lot of wires that didn't lead to
anything and a lot of uh stickers on
there like saying don't do this don't do
that don't do that so it was like all
this [__] that had been engineered to
make it look like yeah but they see
through that they do well they did
figure out that it was fake but it I'm
qualified PBI post blast investigation
and all that [__] they'll just [__]
look at that [__] through an S an x-ray
they'll know exactly all that fake [__]
you put in there you can't [__] with
them they know exactly what they're
doing and they'll hit that bomb with a
disruptor and [__] blow it into
pieces well they always have to do that
any whether it's fake or not my boyy Zan
is in there [__] saying they need to
get me on
iasa man if they put me on iwasa i'
would love to take iasa but if they were
to put me on iasa I'd be talking to
alien souls and [__] you would probably
you [__] record me talking to alien
Souls I could come back with [__]
hidden knowledge about what was going
going on with the [__] on the other
side of the force with the [__]
wheels and [__] [__] I could tell you
everything about how Star Wars worked
come
back George Lucas would be Consulting me
after I was on I I he might even buy you
some I yeah yeah exactly me and George
Lucas doing iasa down in the Yucatan
he's like you know Tom you know I think
story idea I like it I got I got hold on
I got to eras my my my my my neck you
know talk I'm doing got to do when you
do George Lucas you got to get rid of
your [__] neck you know Tom I think
you'd be pretty good at writing Star
Wars stories I think maybe if we take
iasa you could talk to the wheels go
ahead all right go ahead the only thing
that does not appeal to me about iasa is
the vomiting I get over that real quick
I'm not a big fan of vomit I love to
vomit you do he enjoys it I don't enjoy
it I I try not to shoot that [__] out 10
feet if I want to and you're I can talk
in between vomiting well you're very
like chill about it you're just kind of
like yeah I think I might have to throw
up and then he will very calmly like
pull the car over get out of the car go
over to the bushes throw up and then get
back in the car and just drive away like
nothing happen whereas like me the whole
time I'm just like please don't barf but
don't barf don't barf don't barf BL then
I throw up in my [__] lap yeah she
threw up in the car one time I had to
[__] damn hose the car out that was
years ago I think I threw up out the
window well in the car and out the
window I was trying to like not because
I to not cuz I hate and we were 100
yards from the house we were 100 yards
from the [__] house I could have held
on I tried I tried I tried to hold on I
try not to vomit at the best of
situations I really try not I haven't
vomited for a very long time but yeah so
you're good at it that but I don't
turkey neck Lucas [__] right man Don
the bomb knows he looks like [__]
turkey neck Lucas [__] got her
neck see what we're talking about here
most guys are good at puking we've done
it enough I've done it a lot of times
too I just don't I don't like it I don't
like to throw up and and I try not to
throw up until it's inevitable and then
at that point I'm just like well [__]
I'm gonna barf in my lap that sucks yeah
[__] Alex Rivera is saying that IAS
would help me [__] control rspk it
might well you know it might maybe one
of the [__] alien Souls would tell me
explain to me exactly what's going on
and how to do it you get like a [__]
yeah you get like an anxious alien Yoda
come and tell you [__] how to but I
mean the thing is you can get similar
effects from acid and not have the
vomiting issue no iasa is supposed to be
much better it's supposed to be I mean
the only thing acid does is just makes
you feel like really shitty the next day
but not like vomiting shitty but just
like tired and sore shitty some of that
stuff that you take as acid makes you
want makes you wonder if that's actually
LSD because there are a bunch of [__]
uh fakes out there that are real close
like it's a design or
fake and you don't know sometimes it
might be that some of that stuff's legal
some of these so-called illegal drugs
that you're buying are not illegal
because they're not quite the drug you
thought they were well yeah because it's
all to do with like the chemistry you
get like a little thing off and it's
like hey nobody has a law against this
there's a there's a black market illegal
drug Market which is sell this as an
illegal drug it's not illegal though
it's actually just a [__] research
chemical that's legal to possess but
don't tell them yeah it's an
analog so but some of that stuff that
I've taken is like acid like that last
[__] we took this was a couple years
back I thought it was acid but there's a
chance that it was acid like sure that
there's a chance that could have been a
fake though I don't know it had acid
like effects yeah but the fakes do that
The Fakes are real close real real close
it did make me feel like complete crap
the next day though I was like really
and I went to work the next day too
remember cuz I had we had a day off and
we were like Hey we're going going to
like do this on this it was a Tuesday or
some [__] back in the 80s when we could
get the good [__] from the universities
where they were making it [__] on the
slick in the University Laboratories cuz
my buddy my bro was a [__] biochemist
okay [__] we would sit there and
[__] maybe he could get us some good
[__] no no no and then not anymore just
thinking out loud and I'm not anymore
never online I'm gonna say that he can
do
that no it's been too long but uh some
of that [__] we used to get back in the
80s was just [__] fan fantastic it
was like swimming in liquid
honey it was just [__] really good
hallucina you come down it was good
really
good good [__] okay I don't think that
exists anymore I'm not sure if they're
making it like they used
to oh I'm sure someone is somewhere like
lsd2 you know you know that kind of [__]
just been a lot of different we don't
know anybody that has the [__] that's
what I mean you know yeah so all right
so they searched Brian wells's car
not only do they find the cane that
looks like a gun but they also find like
a whole bunch of handwritten notes these
notes were addressed to quote unquote
bomb
hostage now the notes told Brian Wells
that he had to rob the bank of
$250,000 and then he had to follow this
set of like complex instructions to get
like all these keys that would
supposedly Defuse The Bomb like after
you go to the bank like go to the bank
ask for $250,000 come out go to this
McDonald's like at the um the sign like
at the drive-thru there'll be like a
little thing that has a key in IT
that'll do this and it's like so it was
like a scavenger hunt
essentially um so there's all these
drawings in there there's all these maps
in there now the according to the notes
apparently if he did all the [__] in
order in enough time then he would have
been able to diffuse the bomb before it
went off and killed him obviously that
didn't
happen now the thing about this though
is
that um the cops later decided as they
would that they were going to drive this
route that this note says and said what
would it have been possible for him to
you know allegedly like find all these
keys that would diffuse the bomb it was
not possible so I feel like
whoever whe whether Brian Wells was uh
you know a participant that knew about
this going in or was just like an
unwilling participant or whatever it's
like he would not have been able to do
the [__] that it said in the notes to
Defuse The Bomb in time to keep the bomb
from exploding like he was going to die
pretty much regardless of what he did
which you know that's that kind of sucks
so so like I said the cops kind of like
went through the [__] and they were like
okay well well there's no way that he
could have done all this
stuff so let what time is it why is it
time take a break probably I can't see
well it's like an hour and a half I'm
just like losing 627 you probably need
to take a break I probably needed
it all right I tell you
what why don't you
um what why don't you start playing some
commercials all right or do you want me
to sit here with
them
I don't really need to pee I just need
to like find my place in the notes again
this is I thought you needed to take a
break no I don't I don't need to take a
break I just still I just lost my place
in the notes that's all I'm saying say
she don't need to take a pee I don't
need to take a girls are funny I don't
need to pee I call I call it pissing I
have a giant BL okay I I I make fun of
him all the time like when we go out to
the club because he has to pee like
every like seemingly like every 10
minutes I'm a man I was like I can go
all night without peing I'm a man whip
that [__] out and [__] take a piss
wherever I am it's just like it's it's
like a man's privilege it's it's male
privilege we have a [__] we have a
portable urine dispenser we just [__]
unzip pull that [__] out let that [__]
fly you're talking to the dude next to
you man [__] talking about it yeah
man we this and that so there's no
there's no reason for us to hold it
isn't it awesome we don't have to squat
to no squat none of that [__] man
doesn't have to hold it so we never get
these big ass bladders we just [__]
take a
piss like a like a [__] animal
I now I'm wondering if evolution has
given women bigger bladders because of
for that no you're holding it longer see
you're stretching it you're you're
holding it longer so you're stretching
it out you're stretching it out because
you're holding it longer men don't hold
that [__] [__] zanada all you
[__] in the comment section go
ahead and
you put that [__] right there in the
comment section we don't hold it you
guys can back me up on that we don't
hold that [__] we go when we when we
have to hold it it [__] kills us I
don't usually hold it either I just
usually don't have to cuz when dude's
piss man it's like a [__] it's like a
[__] party you know what I'm talking
about it's it's a piss party yeah you
standing next to the dude talking about
something you're going to do this and
that you're both pissing you're talking
and passing a bottle next to each
between each other we should do that
[__] [__] in the Army just [__]
you know
yeah s says I pee all the time it's a
problem yeah you just [__] just let the
[__] fly the only thing that sucks I
will tell you one thing that sucks about
getting older is that I can't sleep
through an entire night without peeing
down which I usually be a like I usually
just get up at and it's usually between
3:00 and 4:00 a.m. yeah and then I have
to get up and pee although I always like
weigh it I always wake up and I'm just
like do I really have to pee that bad
that I have to actually get out of
bed you're [__] funny you know what I
mean and then I'm like sometimes I'm
just like no not worth it I don't have
to pee that bad I to go back to sleep
we're in the new economy though we're
we're we're in the new economy we don't
have to go to the [__] a physical
office somewhere else we don't although
I still get up early get you don't have
bosses but you can do whatever you want
to do so it's not it doesn't matter if
you wake up early or not you can sleep
back in if you want but I noticed that
as I started getting into my late 40s my
sleeping was more efficient four hours
of sleep started to feel like six hours
of sleep you know what I mean and six
hours of sleep started to feel like
eight hours of sleep it's like I didn't
need as much sleep I think when you get
older you don't need as much yeah I
don't think you need as much because I
feel like when you're I mean when you're
in a teenager in your 20s cuz I feel
like like not me because I could never
like sleep all that much but my brothers
they would sleep like all [__] day
like like are you guys ever going to get
up or when I was a teenager I could
sleep through a day and then go through
the night and sleep like [__] like 36
hours I never did that but like my
brothers did my brothers did and I think
it's because [__] um You probably
have a lot of [__] inefficiency in
the in the connections between the
neurons of your brain so there's a lot
of little dendrites [__] going
everywhere so you your thinking is very
fast it's kind of inaccurate but it's
also very imaginative it's like an
inefficient thinking process and as you
get older I think those neural Pathways
start getting ingrained and more
efficient so you don't Tire as readily
and you and and you you kind of [__]
rest a lot faster you know what I'm
talking about I think there was I think
there's a lot of I think the creativity
and energy of Youth is really kind of a
side a side effect of [__]
inefficiency neural inefficiency it's
almost kind of like you're under the
effects of a drug well you're like hyped
up all the time you're hyped up you're
amped up all the time your thinking
isn't very focused or concentrated so
it's all over the place but it's also
real spontaneous you know what I mean
you can come up with new ideas and new
Innovations real easily they may not be
right but they're [__] a trip you
know and for some reason you're because
you're running harder metabolically just
in general when you're especially when
you're a guy and you're under all that
[__] testosterone coming out of
[__] nowhere lots of it you got a
directions like you in this way it's the
equivalent of [__] doing roids
because steroids are just you know it's
just exogenous artif super testosterone
you know healing stuff and you know it
you're under the effect you're basically
under the effects of a [__]
internally generated high performance
drugs that's what it is when you're
young so even when you're even when
you're honestly it it it might be a dude
thing I mean like dude I'm like I'll be
48 about a month from
now and my brain is just Khan woke up
from his old man nap yeah a yeah my
brain is constantly I told him before I
was like can you imagine imine I was
like imagine being on a computer and
having like 30 tabs open at once and
you're just like flicking back and forth
between like all the 30 tabs like all
the time like when you're trying to
sleep and stuff I was like that's what
being in my brain is like I can't stop
thinking about stuff I can't stop
obsessing about stuff I just can't stop
it so I mean I've just kind of like
learned to live with it at this point I
do get some sleep every now and then but
it's like I only sleep in like four or
five hour
blocks everybody's talking about how
much everybody's in the comment section
talking about how much they like to pee
and
[__] kind of crazy ass [__] is it
really I'm just like I I don't know it
just annoys me because I'm just like
working on [__] and I'm like really
right now okay they got all kinds of
[__] man they're talking about how much
they got to wake up [__] all the
girls got to wake up several times while
they [__] asleep you got [__] Alex
R saying how how fatiguing erections are
Alex man when you got a [__] huge
[__] and [__] you can [__] rock up so
bad that you start getting lightheaded
from [__] loss of blood all the blood
blood out you're like out of your brain
[__] and into the dick [__] yeah you
don't know what's going to
happen Celtic Angel she you get it
that's exactly how I am when I'm trying
to get to sleep this is what this is
what I do and even when I was like
working a 9 to-5 job which I hated um
and I knew that I had to get up at you
know 6:00 a.m. 6:30 a.m. which I still
do by the way because I don't know why I
just can't stop doing it um so I would
wake up at 2: or 3 in the morning and
I'd be like okay I still have two hours
I still have three hours that I could
sleep and then I just lay there and I
don't go to sleep and then I'm still
awake when my alarm goes off he can and
K's in the comment section he's talking
about horrible that is when you rock up
so much that you [__] lose
Consciousness he knows all about
that or you get so relaxed that you
start tripping start tripping over that
third leg can't got to [__] rap this
I ain't going talking
about yeah like an elephant's trunk it
is yeah you're like sucking up some
water sucking up water with it Sandra
says my brain works similar that's maybe
why I'm never bored exactly yeah I just
can't I got to go to the restroom y'all
just talking about pissing yeah I got to
check on the cat see the cat yeah go
find Pooky bring her butt well she was
in here W her up she's asleep in the
little oh she's asleep in she's in the
cat tree right outside the office a poor
baby earlier she was sleeping on this
this Mac over here like if you can see
it that say it open she fell asleep like
on the
keyboard and she like all stretched
across it and she was like sleeping with
her little and she was drooling on it
and everything so I don't really know if
it's still going to work or not but I
just let her because she was cute but
yeah
so that's the thing it's like I try to
sleep I really do try to
but 3: and 4 between 3:00 and 4: every
morning I wake up and I'm just like well
how many hours do I still have to sleep
before I can wake up because the thing
is it's like I like to wake up earlier
than Tom does because I can get up I can
go walk three miles I can like do my
weights I can do all this other stuff I
can like get some [__] done like it's in
peace and quiet before he gets up and
starts making noise and whatnot so it's
like I try to get up like a lot earlier
than him so I'll be in my office and
it'll be like 9 or 10 in the morning and
he'll like finally be getting up and
like coming in here with his coffee and
I've already been up at for like four
hours at this point and I'm just like
dude my workday is like half over at
this stage I don't know it's just very
funny to me I don't know why it's like I
used to be I used to not get up
naturally until about 10: in the morning
because I used to always work night
shift I worked from uh 5:30 at night to
2: in the morning um and I wouldn't get
home till 3:00 or 4: in the morning
because I worked kind of far away so I
got used to like being on a night shift
so I would like sleep most of the day
and then I would like get up and do [__]
in the afternoon but it's like I don't
know why like the last few years I've
just started getting up really early and
like now I get up before it even is
light
out and while you're sitting here what
have you got You' got a hat yeah while
you're sitting here talking about peeing
I got to [__] put my jungle hat on
I'm in the jungle now what is I'm in the
jungle now peeing has to do with jungle
I'm just talk I'm in Florida I'm in the
jungle okay I'm in a jungle where is uh
in the jungle of alcohol where is
where's Pooky at sleeping in the damn
cat tree she's in the bowl I told them
that she was sleeping on the Mac earlier
and she seemed very um put out that I
was calling her out about it get that
[__] [__] all cocked off to the side
all sexy and [__] very Rish yeah [__]
R like something out of goddamn
movies I like
it all right so can we get back to
talking about that you're the one to
stop talking man was I I'm not
controlling this [__] I'm you're running
this
show you're running this why does it not
feel like that sometimes you're running
this when's the halfway part um isn't it
we're already at an hour and 40 minutes
man that's [__] halfway as [__] man
this is going be a hour only four
[__] paragraphs you people are
getting a treat tonight this is going to
be an extra long show it probably will
because went up I haven't even look look
I'm still talking about the [__]
bankrupt I you talked about like all the
conspirators and all that [__] how how
many of these people need to [__]
drink how many of them need to drink
everybody does anybody need to get up
and get a drink sh is this time to take
a break or what at least you know unless
you don't want to drink alcohol which
I'm not judging but you know like I said
yeah can I can I talk about it I'm very
drunk and just jumping into the stream
feels trippy that's what Thomas Carl
said they tell me what a great hat this
is this is like a pure guys safari hat
it's got that [__] damn Vietnam tiger
stripe Vietnam tiger strip honestly wish
that we could have like filmed because
okay you remember like the last like a
couple other live streams ago that we
did Show's cutting into be beess porn
time dude you can jerk that [__] later
at any time them girls are on call man
yeah there's all the porn you want your
fingertips yeah which you guys are
spoiled that [__] never happened like
when we were growing up you couldn't
just like find porn for you know it
they're gonna have damn [__]
AI porn controlled [__] sex bots
coming raping these men out of nowhere I
kind jump up out of a box and just try
to be the top on a [__] trying
to peg him and [__] these [__] robot
women you better watch it because you
know they're going to get in there and
[__] with that AI programming okay
they're going to get them F Well if I
invented it them feminists are going to
get in there and then before you know it
something's going to rock up on that
female robot your but like that what are
you going to do [__] stronger than a
human it's got you by the ankles and
[__] what are you going to do yep I
ain't buying no sex robots can't trust
them y'all going to get a little flavor
little flavor of what women have had to
put up with you're gonna get it no stop
it
J all right no I don't even remember
what I was saying but yeah you
recommended to be the my ass's haunted
movie I think that my ass is haunted
movie that has like that has B in it had
B B's in that I love B she's my favorite
B's her favorite I love B I love Bono's
into that [__] and I love like she has
like she from buy Mississippi too teeth
she's super cute I love her she was from
buuy Mississippi same time I was there
but I didn't run into her at least if I
did I didn't I didn't know but she might
have been hanging out with the clubs she
she probably was she is also go a
fantastic entrepreneur man because I
have been to Fair Villa like the sex
shop here in Orlando you can buy every
part of her yeah and look like they got
her [__] they got her tits they got
everything and she is a [__] I was
like I just I walked through there and
filmed it one day I was just like I got
it give the girl props they don't know
what Fairville is faville is a sex
genius yeah it's well it's very famous
it's been here for like [__] Christ
man how long has it been here as long as
I've as long as I remember 20 years 30
I don't
know Bell's Bell's from Mississippi
that's a Mississippi
girl she's awesome I love her she's from
buuy yeah and she knows exactly what
she's
doing yeah she's like I like [__]
business man I don't think her parents
were from Mississippi though I think her
parents were Mormons I think her dad was
in the [__] well that explains a lot
I think I think her I think her dad was
in the Air Force Base there at buxy
that's what I think where she came from
but according to her I read her bio she
was hanging out a lot in the French
Quarter during the same time I was there
so I probably cross paths where there I
was goth out as a
[__] hanging out at the Crystal
and at the convent she probably came
through there but I you know I can't
remember everybody that's where I met my
first wife and Jerry
Springer if you guys don't know he he
told that story like before on the show
but yeah he met Jerry Springer Jerry
Springer was cool as [__] he's cool dude
he was real cool dude we were at the
[__] we were at the um me and him
we're sitting on these damn wicker
chairs in this private club called the
convent watching this couple couple go
through this BT BDSM
show and [__] Jerry was [__] up man
and [__] he was buying drinks and I'd
buy him a round and he'd buy me round
and [__] [__] and I was going Jerry I
was like Jerry man [__] with me he oh
she's beautiful man oh man she's
beautiful he just he's just normal guy
you know just cool [__] [__] funny
Glenn little says I like that gap in her
teeth I yeah yeah she's cute yeah she's
I like there's something about I'm
really into chicks that have like an
quote unquote imperfection but that use
that to their advantage so like I'm
really into that for some reason I don't
know why it's like just make that [__]
work for you I like it it so yeah so
yeah so this guy gets his head blown off
not literally but you know like the bomb
goes off so the authorities start
looking into this case which like I said
is weird enough as it is this dude comes
into a bank and he says nud I have a
bomb it's like strapped around my neck
give me $250,000 hey we only have 8700
so that'll have to do and then he gets
caught and then he blows up on live TV
so you know so this [__] story goes
all over the world because it's super
weird and like I said the
FBI have even gone on to saying this is
pretty much the only case we have like
this like we have one to two% of like
bank robberies do involve somebody
coming in saying they have a bomb but
it's 99.99% of the time it's always like
a fake bomb this is the only time that
it's been a real one so I don't think
they actually believe that it was a real
bomb I don't know if the dude believe it
was ear
bomb so they start like looking into the
[__] so they start out at mam Mia's
Pizzeria which is where Brian Wells
worked what you look like you're going
to say something no I was thinking about
what somebody asked me you like a girl
with a tail I was thinking [__] [__] you
talking about somebody said that in the
comment section said only if that Tail's
on the end of a plug but no go ahead go
ahead go ahead well well what does the
tail look
like no I'm openminded
no no what do you have like a long like
Avatar tail like a lion tail I like it I
like it all right so Brian Wells is
working at this place called Mama M's
Pizzeria so they find out that on the
day of the heist an order had come in at
1:30 p.m. uh for two small sausage and
pepperoni pizzas to be delivered to this
location on the outskirts of Erie
Pennsylvania now Brian Wells had worked
at this pizza
for 10 years and he was a very loyal
employee the only time he had called in
sick was when his cat had died which
that upset me when I read it because I
was like I don't I don't like to hear
about cat's dying because you know how I
am so he goes out and he delivers the
[__] which was like at this house that
was like by like a old like TV tower it
was like the end of a dir road so he
left at like 2 p.m. so so they find this
place it's this house off a dirt road
next to the TV transmission station off
of peach
street so the investigators go out there
they find uh Brian wells's um you know
tire tracks that match his car and they
find uh footprints that match his shoes
that he was wearing when he died so
they're wondering at this point now did
somebody actually like was he in on this
or did somebody like lure him into this
plan like I said for a long time it was
thought that he was kind of like just
this pizza dude that got called out and
then he got a bomb strapped to his neck
and then [__]
insu so that was kind of how it went for
uh a long
time so at this stage so they um they
have like a photographer and a reporter
from the newspaper they are out there
like the day after the EXP expion and
they're kind of wandering around this
area and they see this tall dude with
overalls
on and he's kind of pacing in front of
this house that's like right next to
this TV
Tower and they ask him about who he is
and this dude says that his name is Bill
Rothstein now this is a guy that's very
important to the investigation
so this guy who at the time was 59 years
old he was a a handyman he had lived in
the area uh pretty much his entire
life now people at the time that
interviewed him said that he was very um
well spoken he was very eloquent uh like
someone who had you know maybe studied
like you know the English language and
was very kind of up on that kind of [__]
he sounded like a very intelligent
person so so um he also it ended up when
they uh found out later that he was also
uh he also spoke French and he also
spoke
Hebrew now the journalists at the time
who were just investigating the bomb you
know the collar bomb case they didn't
think that he had anything to do with it
at the time just that he happened to
live by there but he's like hey can we
kind of like film around your property
and he said fine so he like showed them
around his yard and and whatnot and so
then it turns out that this guy was kind
of like going to be the key to the whole
[__]
situation
because less than a month after the bank
robbery this same dude with the overalls
Bill
Rothstein called
911 and told them you know at 8645 pach
Street
there's a frozen body in the garage that
was his own house that's when the
[__] plot tick it that was his own
house yeah and he said it's in the
freezer in the garage there's a dead
body so you need to come out and check
that
out so the cops come out they find this
[__] body in the freezer which this
is [__] and they showed this a little
bit on the documentary like the body had
been in the freezer I think he'd been in
there for five weeks so he was like in
kind of a fetal position he was frozen
like that so when they pulled him out he
was still in this fetal position like on
the top of the [__]
freezer and um yeah so the dude is
basically like I didn't kill the guy but
I was asked to stash the body I'll tell
you guys about it later but you know
just come get it that was basically what
he
said now he said when he gets brought
into custody obviously because the dead
body has been found on his property um
he said yeah this has been like an
ongoing [__] he's like I was going to
kill myself um he had written a suicide
note which they found later at a
desk and he says that the body in the
freezer belongs to a dude named Jim rhen
now he says I didn't kill the guy I
didn't participate in the dude's death I
just had to do with like hiding the body
and weirdly one thing that he said at
the very beginning of the note that he
wrote about you know who the body was
and [__] like that he said this has
nothing to do with the wells case I.E
the bank robbery with the colar bomb
which you know authorities were like
well that's a little
suspicious so he's in custody for a
couple of days and they you know the
police are questioning him obviously
they're like okay well how did this dead
dude end up in your
freezer bill says okay mid August he
says I get this phone call from my
ex-girlfriend this woman named margerie
deal Armstrong he's like I dated her uh
a long time ago like in the late 60s
early 70s we were engaged to be married
but then it didn't work out um you know
if if you've seen the documentary she
was actually quite a a beautiful woman
back in the day
um so apparently she had told Bill she's
like look uh I shot my current boyfriend
with a shotgun hold on let me say
goodbye to Khan all right Khan you have
a good one bro he's up in [__] TJ
getting drunk on that damn Bohemian
beard it's [__] during a heatwave
saying goodbye to everybody half a damn
[__] half half the damn comment sections
just lit y'all ought to be ashamed of
yourself so are we drinking drinking
drinking and [__] like all the stress
has come off me now because I feel like
I don't have to be quite so coherent
they're all [__] they're all [__]
up I'm just trying to like read my notes
without good up too much hold
on so it helps if you guys are drunk to
he said he's still there oh you going
somewhere hey hey Dan says what sort of
freezer they got I can only get arms and
legs in mine stay here and [__] drink
B this one was it was like basically
squished into like a fetal position like
like the knees were up like that they
had a thought out for several hours
before they could do like an autopsy or
anything like I saw I saw the uh the
video where they were pulling the video
out or they were pulling the body out of
the freezer and the knees were all like
that
yeah all right KH cool he's not going
anywhere he's saying goodbye to somebody
else oh okay that's you need to stay
here [__] drink that [__] beer bro
yeah we're all good there ain't nowhere
to go on TJ man Tiana's F Tiana all
right look
I know you got all them cute girls out
there selling all that all their bodies
on the [__] streets of Tijana but
you're a married man and you got [__]
booze and a whole [__] family you sit
there and drink that Bohemian beer bro
we're going to put on a whole show for
you don't go
anywhere gota got you guys got to
understand something about the the
friendship I have with Khan Khan of oon
all right because we know about the
coming oon all right out of the blue
I'll be up on up in in bed watching
[__] movies with Jenny and KH will
send me a photo of some Mexican girl's
ass yeah like last night we were
watching original Star Trek yeah and it'
be a fine ass you know what I mean and
being a South American man Me growing up
in Brazil we we understand each other
okay
and a lot of North American people
especially when you're talking about up
way up North with all them [__]
hardcore Yankees they wouldn't approve
of our behavor behavior and our
mentality but he's just like look at
that I'm like oh yeah that's right and
then a discussion might break out about
some faceless booty and ass ass we're
just talking about the roundness the
fullness maybe certain angles it's like
a fine art it's very mathematical yes
it's a fine art it's like art
appreciation see they don't understand
it up north they don't have a an art
appreciation course at Harvard
University to understand the Latina ass
okay the Latina ass has a certain
Dynamic to it
okay no one race has a monopoly on ass
or actitude but there each race and each
blend has its own gestal
okay a connoisseur of ass understands
all right I can't explain any longer all
right it's like how can you explain the
color yet yellow how could you explain
the color red you have to experience it
firsthand okay Jen that's all I got to
say I feel like my white SL Native
American ass is pretty cool yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's each one each one is
individual yes he does this while I'm
watching Star Trek I we were watching
original Star Trek last night on Netflix
and the whole time I was pretty [__]
up I have to say it was Friday night and
I was like drinking a lot and I was just
like why are they always picking on
Spock he's always right about everything
why why does nobody listen to
spock you know that was just that one
episode though they were showing the
limits of logic that was the the episode
was SP here's it well Spock was running
to Galileo and the [__] that made me
mad about that because everyone was like
[__] on Spock after was like oh you
got all emotional about why did you like
blow all the fuel so they could like see
the signature of the fuel it's like when
you could have like you had like an hour
of fuel left and I was like dude that
was a totally logical decision because
the you know the [__] um what do you
call it the statistics being if you
couldn't
see where the ship
was um but maybe if you could see the
ship was or if you blew your [__]
Fuel and you only had 6 minutes of it
left that seems like the more logical
decision to me yeah so it's like I don't
know why they were like picking on him
for that being an emotional decision
because that was a completely logical
decision now there's all kinds of guys
in the com in the comment section is
understanding about the the the the the
the [__] tan Brown bubbles uh [__]
um what episode somebody what is the
name of that episode we watching Isaac
Newton Isaac Newton level
science uh that was the I think it was
called it was the it was in the first
season I think it was episode 16 it was
either balance of Terror it was one
after that it was after that BAL of
Terror had the rulin in it that's right
it was uh it was about the Galileo the
little shuttlecraft Spock has run the
shovel craft it crash lands on a [__]
planet where they have to fight these
gigantic aliens the big fur big fur Yeti
that are throwing these gigantic Spears
and guys are getting killed and Spock's
trying to get them off the damn Planet
he has to turn the [__] Galileo into
a damn [__] uh well he has to burn
all the fuel he has like an hour worth
of fuel left makes like a big flare so
the [__] yeah he's like look I only have
six minutes like if I burn it all I'll
only have six minutes but it'll be more
likely that it will be seen by the
Enterprise and I was like that was a
totally logical decision and it's like
by the time they rescue them because
obviously they do and they get back on
the [__] ship everyone's like picking
on Spock because like oh you made an
emotional decision I'm like it wasn't
though it was a it was a completely
logical decision well there was a bunch
of other stuff that had now we're CR now
we're now we're critiquing [__] Star
Trek episodes all right just make me mad
that's all all right in that particular
one in that particular one there was
showing the limitations of logic in the
application of the leadership
role because it it has to do with mass
psychology and leading groups of men
logic isn't enough there also has to be
some empathy and emotion but yeah box
logic did save them in the end it did
because like I said from a statistical
standpoint it was way more likely that
they would see the burnout than they
would see them just like drifting around
but during that Journey all right Spock
was questioning what he was doing and
people were questioning Spock's
leadership abilities and yeah in the end
it worked out yeah but the road was kind
of rough to that that that's all they're
talking about it wasn't saying that
logic was
not useful or bad it was just saying
that the average person doesn't think
that way yeah yeah it worked all right
yeah but then there was the question of
was that desperation that caused him to
[__] actually
risk making the signal flare was that
emotion did he actually use emotion to
save the club the the the the the crew
and that's what that's what they let you
decide you wouldn't have had to because
like I said in the situation that was
the most logical decision to make
because if you like said like look How
likely is it that they will see this
[__] [__] this is all I'm going to
say without like or is it more likely
that they'll see it if I burn out all
the fuel and they'll see this big flare
I mean I feel like that's the most
logical decision to make in that
situation there's this [__] Spock and
Kirk dynamic between me and Jenny
Jenny's like Spock I'm more like [__]
Kirk and I'm GNA [__] say something
and hoping you guys will agree with me
so people don't like don't pick on Spock
man the beauty of Star Trek is that it
did not force a conclusion on you it
showed you a story and it let you decide
and that story was a good example of
that it let you decide was Spock
actually working through logic or was he
working through emotion really in the
end and it let you decide yeah but like
I said from my point of view it seemed
like the most logical thing to do
because it's like look I only have 45
minutes of fuel left it's like probably
like from a statistical standpoint
probably no one's going to see us so
it's like if I burn all the fuel out
like I'll have six minutes where maybe
they'll see us and it's way more likely
that they'll see us so that seems like a
more logical decision to me yeah okay
well I'm just saying that's that seemed
like a logical deis in my experience and
I've been in life and death situations a
lot of I'm a going to talk about that
[__] on the show too personal but in my
in my personal experience with this kind
of
situation it's a
mixture yeah you're using logic but
there's emotion behind it and [__]
and and [__] [__] desperation is a
hell of a [__] emotion just like
cocaine is a hell of a drug just ask
for well when you don't have anything
left to lose I mean you know my knowing
Star Trek knowing the writing knowing
how it was it was a mixture Spock felt
emotion he was half human he just kept
the [__] in check sure so and even
Vulcans felt emotion they like I said
that's kind of why I relate to him as a
character and like I get like I don't
know I get like weirdly like annoyed
like when people pick on him for [__]
because it's like he usually ends up
being right in most situations well the
writers are not picking on him the
writers are using the other characters
as an example of what average people
were like yeah especially in the context
of the time of the late 60s there was a
way to show the strengths of
Spock yeah right I was like clearly
Spock is the best character yeah they're
both good Our Friend Sophie who is much
younger than us probably like young
enough to be our daughter maybe H not
that young but um she is watching Star
Trek the Original Series for the first
time and we're kind of watching it too
we're only like an episode to episode or
two ahead of her and so she's she's
never seen it before so she's kind of
like coming at it with like fresh eyes
and it's like really neat to like watch
it cuz I've seen all the original series
episodes like a couple of times so it's
really cool to like watch it in the
context of like someone that's never
seen it before cuz she's like messaging
him like while we're watching it and
it's like it's really cool to like see
somebody like that wasn't even born when
this well I wasn't born when the [__]
was on either but who wasn't even born
when the [__] was
going to you know get really into it and
get really into these like character
like interactions and stuff because that
was that was the thing that I loved
about the original theories more than
saying I'm more like O'Reilly than Kirk
O'Reilly was the [__] I come on come on
Kirk I was telling him last night it's
like I had I saw the the Mystery Science
Theater parody of that scene before I
saw the actual episode cuz we watched
that episode last night where they went
on the planet it's called Shor leave
where they went on the planet it was
like aliceon what it was like the rabbit
and Alice and like every like everything
that everybody thought of would like
come to life yeah so it's like and then
like Kirk I guess he was still thinking
about some dude in like [__] Academy
that was like gonna kick his ass or
whatever he was still thinking about
that many years later for whatever
reason and uh so it was an Irish dude so
he wanted to beat that dude up yeah so
that kind of happened like and all I
could think of the whole time I was
watching that was the MST K saying we
need to do a Star Trek show we should
yeah I'm like I I haven't seen like a
lot of the he made me watch all of
Enterprise um and I've seen most of like
deep space and I I've seen all the
others but the original one is still my
favorite yeah because I love Spock I
love Spock and I love the interaction
between him and Kirk and Bones I just
love that
whole right now saying he feels like an
uncultured slob that haven't never
watched it it's on Netflix you should
watch the original series it's a
cultural icon and it transcends [__]
Western culture I know that there are
people in India that [__] like it um
China would probably like it um I don't
think Japan got big off into it I think
some people did
but I think uh in in India I think
Indian culture would understand it a lot
um it's a good series excellent series
it still holds up today I like I I just
never get style is different it's very
comforting to watch actually it's very
theatrical it's uh it's it's very
morality taish uh very kind of
comforting kind of put you into a little
like a like a [__] Zone really it's
like watching The Twilight Zone or well
yeah it's a lot of the same writers yeah
a lot of same writers but we got to move
on actually let's get back to the case
so we're going to be doing a 5 hour show
and I know right we're already two hours
and eight minutes now before we go on is
is it time to take any kind of break or
anything I don't know do you want to do
you want to do a break or what are you
all right yeah I'm fine okay I'm fine
too okay all right um let me see what
else um does anybody want any shirts
does anybody still out there if you send
us $20 in the comment section send us a
$20 Super Chat I will send you a shirt
of your size and whatever kind you want
just go ahead and just uh put that in
there um what else down bom says bones
damn you you green blooded yeah feel I
feel like bones and Spock yeah bones
kind of loved Spock but he didn't want
to admit it by the by the second season
they wrote in they wrote in this [__]
Triad where it was kind of like this
Bromance between that was the best I
love that I love that aspect Kirk Spock
and McCoy and they were all different
and they were all [__] bromancing and
[__] festing all right that's what they
were that's what they did I know it's
fantastic that's fantastic the best
thing about that it's like a bunch of
[__] you just get them all together
and but that's that's really what made
that show because it's three different
elements explaining and expounding on
one another you have Kirk who's kind of
like The Dashing emotional kind of
hot-headed but decisive leader he's a
hero got you got Spock who's kind of
this logical guy who's under control
keeping it in check but he's kind of
dark and mysterious then you got bones
who is this compassionate every man
who's [__] calling [__] on Spock
and trying to convince him that he's a
[__] man and that he's human and then
he's also telling [__] Kirk to chill
the [__] out and put that dick back in
your pants and stop getting in trouble
so and then they start checking bones
saying bones you know you like ladies
you know you can't control yourself
around women so it's this [__] Triad
[__] goes on between two that's just
[__] work that's what made that feel
like the the subsequent um other Star
Trek shows which I liked but I feel like
it was a little lacking just because it
didn't have that that yeah well the
first yeah the first season they were
trying to figure out what the recipe was
how are they going to keep this going
second season that's really when it hit
it strride third season they started to
kind of run out of ideas you know what I
mean it's it's it's not a bad season but
it's the weakest season they're they're
really [__] I mean the second season
was probably the best one I mean because
I feel like that was kind of like I feel
like what happened at the beginning
because I was telling you this last
night was that I feel like at the
beginning they wanted like Kirk to be
like the hero quote unquote of the show
but when a lot of people um identified
with Spock um like I did later on then
they said well we need to give him like
a bigger role in the show so I feel like
they did more [__] with his character in
the second season which I really liked
so they really like you know emphasized
Oracle m mom P pointed something out the
tri Triad
was super you're right ex you're right
it was that's why it worked yeah that's
why it worked there was a similar
Dynamic
yeah that's exactly where yeah the
original series is awesome if you like
the original series The Original Series
in the third Series in the third season
just kind of
ends but Vic manona and the same kind of
writers and a lot of the same people
that starred or the children that
starred in the original series did a
free series on YouTube that's [__]
just as good it's excellent called Star
Trek Continues and I think it's only
about seven or eight episodes and it
wraps it up I thought it was 11 maybe
it's said was it 11 I think it was 11 it
wraps it up and it joins it up to Star
Trek the motion pitch they did a good
job I yeah real good job we did a r like
I I was actually impressed by how
closely they like adhere to the and like
yeah yeah and like they finished off
like a lot of the original episodes and
they finished up a bunch of loose ties
like the mirror episode you know uh with
the evil Spock with the beard there's a
part two of that of what the evil Spock
did back in the other Universe sex yeah
it's my [__] favorite episode
actually I mean was pretty sexy the way
it was yeah evil Spock was better but
evil Spock was even more sex he wasn't
evil none of them were really evil they
were morally gray SP were ruthless they
were they were more like ruthless they
were kind of like something out of the I
me Spock that's all I'm saying you know
I'm not going to apologize for that well
actually Spock he was a sex symbol
during during those days that's good so
I'm not the only one a weirdo but like I
said it's like every time we watch the
original series I'm just like quit
picking on Spock it's like he's right in
this [__] situ like in the last one
that we were watching like like I said I
was kind of drunk like watching it I was
just like he saved all those people
because he did the [__] with the fuel
and I'm like you're welcome yeah I know
you all bitched at me but my boy KH
Point points out that [__] Star Trek
continue kind of choke you up at the end
especially towards the end last series
IED where find out why why did [__]
Spock leave [__] SE why did he leave
the why did he leave Starfleet why did
[__] Kirk take the desk job all that
[__] you know because he just when
motion pitch starts there coming out of
retirement it explains what happens yeah
it's it's good I will tell like I'm not
ashamed I will tell you at the end of
Star Trek Continues yeah you're like oh
man
it's like because they got the music
perfect and everything I cried yeah if
you know if you if you know all the
movies you understand exactly yeah I did
so what were we talking about yeah oh
this Bank yeah go ahead go to rest go
ahead go ahead keep going oh there it
goes yeah I got [__] I got to do did you
yeah okay he's going to go that is she
still on the she's still sleep sleeping
in the [__] okay it's still light out
weird all right so as I said this
[__] this bank heist it
happen now this guy Bill rosstein calls
the cops and says hey I have a body in
my freezer it's a gy radent I didn't
kill him but I stored him there so
please come check this [__] out so they
take bill into
custody and over the next two days he
says that in mid August a little bit
before the bank heist had occurred he
said I got a phone call from this woman
that he used to date called margerie
deal
Armstrong and apparently she had
allegedly shot her live-in boyfriend at
the time Jim
Rhoden and uh they were having like a
fight over money evidently so she shot
him in the back with a ring 12 gauge
shotgun and she needed some help getting
rid of the
body so in cleaning up the scene too
because you know you shoot somebody
there's blood everywhere so there's 10
miles between Bill's Place and Mar's
place so Bill decides he's going to do
what she tells him to do now Evil Genius
the Netflix documentary goes into this a
little bit now I will say that margin
deal
Armstrong was in her day she was a
beautiful beautiful woman and many
people at the time said that she was
very good at getting people to do what
she wanted them to do like she was very
intelligent she was very
manipulative so it does seem that bill
Rothstein was kind
of at the stage where she would call him
and ask him it's like hey can you hide
hi a body for me and he was like sure
why not which I don't get that but what
what is that you got a package it was at
the front door oh that's probably like
shampoo or something shamp you want to
open it and see it's an unboxing it's
probably just shampoo or shower gel or
something it's heavy whatever it is I
have I have a subscription
too you guys are probably getting
excited over
[Laughter]
nothing shampoo a [__] ton of it four
bottles of it that's good yeah put that
[__] in storage that's shampoo for the
apocalypse I'm out of shampoo actually
so it's good that it
arrived oops drunk I'm going kick [__]
when I'm drunk you made you made
his yeah so so bill says
look I I loved this woman so much that
when she called me up and said hey I
killed a dude can you hide the body for
me D he was all like okay and I'm all
like what is this bitch's secret cuz I
would like to know it but I don't know
so he puts the body in the freezer in
his garage and all of these people it
should be said are
hoarders if you've seen the inside of
any of there like his house her house I
it there's garbage everywhere there's
like it's just like a [__] episode of
Hoarders except with bodies you know
what I'm saying yeah so yeah so they
open the freezer there's the body in
there it it has been in there for five
weeks another thing that he did other
than hiding the body was that he took
the shotgun that she had killed the
boyfriend with and melted it down and
then like melted it down in little
pieces and then like threw the pieces
around like little paranoid H well well
that's kind of a dumbass because
shotguns don't leave any forensic EV
evidence on the projectiles that kill
anybody it's pellets right but it's not
rifling she just didn't know what she
was
doing wor too much another thing that he
did and he said later that he was just
doing this to make her happy that he
wasn't actually going to do it but
another thing that he did was he went to
some place I'm assuming like a
restaurant supply store and bought a
meat grinder because he told her he was
going to grind up the body dumb asses as
meat I don't think he ever actually
bought it or he didn't like actually
bring it to the place I think he just
told her that he was going to do that
just to get her off his damn dumb ass
these people come up with these [__]
weird ass ways of disposing human bodies
they've never field dressed a deer
they've never butchered a deer there's
no no [__] experience of this [__]
they make it this maab [__] thing you
know what I mean well I'm going to have
to get a
chainsaw
Paleolithic man
okay would reduce an entire elephant
down to [__] bite-sized portable
portions with small handheld pieces of
volcanic
glass a small [__] knife small boning
knife a small kitchen knife you can
reduce a person down to [__] little
bitty pieces that could be packed away
and sold or served or something you know
what I mean without even [__] making
a mess in your damn kitchen hopefully
what you're doing oh py after you you
going to put your butt in the camera
everybody wants you to it's always weird
like you look at these [__]
like oh what's his name Ed gain well
they're overthinking it they overthink
the goddamn [__] they [__] make a
goddamn mess there's [__] maggots and
[__] leaving body parts around and
everything I mean I know they're kind of
into that [__] but they're making it
like a [__] unsanitary [__]
charnal house it's just like somebody
says Cher wood chipper even that's too F
why why hey what's up oh my good hey
Pooky meat is
biodegradable you know don't make such a
fuss about it you know you can put it in
I'm not going to teach people how to get
rid of [__] bodies but all you
probably not the best idea yeah it's
just when you understand nature I guess
you know having a country background and
understanding the field a lot she going
to stick her butt in the camera I don't
know what you're going to do but po look
at the
camera it's very clean and easy and
[__] very natural and not spooky or
morbid in any way to dispose of any kind
of body deer or whatever deer or human
there's not a big difference other than
the differences that being sounds just
throw it in the swamp alligators will
exactly thank you exactly thank you very
much bro um or be did I just get paid
for advice for Sound Advice you better
watch yourself bro see I thank you very
much I keep all afraid to got to work
afraid to got to work tomorrow take care
okay Don thanks bro okay we'll all be
there for you tomorrow
seriously send a Super Chat I'll read
that [__]
[Laughter]
out so Bill calls 911 like I said and
said that look I have this body in my
freezer I didn't kill him it was
margorie deal Armstrong she shot the
dude that was her boyfriend asked me to
like store the body put it in my freezer
so it's been in there for somebody's
asking me how long will it take to
reduce the
body okay more or less the [__]
biomass of your average human beings
going to be real similar to a deer you
can field dress a deer and reduce it
down to parts that can be frozen okay
and eaten and sold within about an
hour you know and uh that's good to know
without any mess thank you Ken thank you
very much Ken you're red your shirt's
coming too we just sent it yesterday
yeah yeah Ken you're [__] throwing
serious cash my way bro I love
[Laughter]
you so uh no they're they're making a
big deal about nothing and it doesn't
well these are not master criminals
talking and it doesn't take a big knife
and it doesn't take chainsaws and those
[__] weird [__] they come up with
you're just making a mess yeah you're
going make you're put blood evidence all
over your house that they will find with
luminol haven't you guys seen [__]
any True Crime shows or nothing yeah the
the okay I'm going to go this
far
[__] when you're hunting all right and
you're you shoot a deer inside the
[__] kill
zone at the place where the deer is
killed there's a ring of [__] blood
spray and fur at the bullet impact cuz
you're where the deer was killed because
it's it's usually a rifle bullet all
right
if it's a good hit the the deer usually
is either killed instantly right there
or they [__] run about 10 20 feet
then they
die to remove the deer from the [__]
location it's they tend to be heavy look
at this [__] head coming up [__] you
doing turn around look at the camera say
hi to everybody she's looking at me like
what are we talking about yeah she's
like what what what did he say then she
looks at me
okay we do a thing called field dressing
that's what you [__] stand a deer
up stick a knife in its booty booty hole
and go up go up to its [__] chest
area you kind of go through the rib cage
then you reach in there with the tip of
your knife and there's this viscous
material that runs around the inside the
body cavity that connects all the
internal organs and you start cutting
with that you have very really small
sharp curved knife you return you you
cut that viscous material there it's
like a connect connective material you
see it when you're in there then you
pick the deer up by the [__]
shoulders of the head you lift him up
and all the guts will fall out there's a
couple places where you can cut it and
it'll fall free and you leave the guts
on site all right the animals will get
that that night you come back the next
day that shit's gone always because that
we would
hunt backto back days in the same
location and every time you feel dress a
deer when you came back that next
morning those [__] guts were gone
bossoms get him come on poke come on
down here a you gonna jump off she's
like I had to get my butt in the camera
at something get stage all
right once the deer is field dressed
it's a lot lighter because the internal
organs have a lot of fluid in it it
weighs a lot more so once it's field
dressed you can then move the deer and
you can take it
home string the deer up by the antlers
string him up from from bottom of of a
tree and you cut around the [__]
Hooves front and back Hooves cut down
the insides of the [__] legs towards
the center cut around the neck grab him
by the Scruff of the neck and pull all
that skin off you don't have to do that
on a human it's too thin all right
you're just trying to get rid of fur you
take a hacks saww you cut the back legs
off and then you cut down at the knee on
both the back legs actually you don't
need a hacks saw for the for for the
inside leg just on the [__] under the
knees and you take and so you have the
whole rumps you can take shoulders off
but there's not a lot of meat there then
there's two flaming Ys that run down the
backbones going from the [__] back of
the head all the way down towards the
tail and you get in there with a knife
you take that off the rest of it just
[__] bone and head you don't really
need anything else take the deer down
take a hacksaw cut the antlers off and
keep them that's your score for the for
the season because at the end of the
season you and your buddies all [__]
count up the points who got most points
for the year because each one of those
little spikes is little horns as a
point uh a deer [__] gains two points
every year of his life so the idea is to
have the deer in your Zone get as old as
they possibly can before the kill so
you're culling your biggest strongest
male deers well hopefully they already
had Offspring because they've had
Offspring that's why you're doing it and
some clubs in some zones you have to
have hunting rights in Mississippi all
right unless it's an open area where
it's free but
mostly in the county that we lived and
you had to have hunting rights okay and
you have to buy those we bought them
from the Masonite
Corporation because it was logging
land um our club Rule and there was only
four guys that had the rights to the
land and and visitors I was one of the
[__] visitors our rules was is that
you couldn't kill anything four points
and Below you couldn't have it so a deer
had to be at least three years old is a
six point Point okay before you could
take a shot only amateur is going to
shoot a spike or a fourpoint you know
what I mean that's desperation that's
that's that's scraping the bottom of the
barrel you want eight point 10 point I'm
not a ver to hunting point maybe but at
least know what you're doing yeah yeah
well the idea is not to this is a Yankee
concept the civilian concept where you
hunt an animal to Extinction that's a
[__] no holy crap the idea is to [__]
have a territory and rights on a
land you seed it with the best foods
that these animals like you can't bait
them that's leaving out apples okay but
you can plant the food that they eat
there and you make a paradise to attract
them you allow them to breed there for a
long period of time so you can hunt from
a [__] strong breeding population so
you're not killing deer you're creating
deer deer there's more deer than they
would normally be you understand what
I'm talking especially around here there
are deer they're [__] everywhere
everywhere but in
Mississippi good hunters and good
hunting clubs are creating deer there's
an excess of deer Dan says you need a
hunting license over there yeah you do
yeah yeah and these These are deer
production zones because they're [__]
reproducing and they're walking out into
other people's [__]
clubs you know what I'm talking about
they're you they're spilling over they
don't stay because the Bucks drive drive
each other out they're like get the [__]
out of here you're too small to be here
I'm they're all trying to dominate the
herds of females they don't want the
younger males there they're all fight to
stay you know but a lot of them are
driven out into other people's areas
okay yeah get the males out of here yeah
males are [__] kind of like they're
they're a Nuance they're a nuisance to
the deer just like in human life in a
normal situation where you building a
deer Paradise it's like seven or eight
[__] dominant bucks that are like six
to 10 years old now they're six to eight
years old maybe six seven years old
maybe they're like that age and they're
driving all the young ones out you know
what I mean but but they're trying to
keep control of about 15 Doe's 20 doe
yeah good luck with that but it works
good luck it works because the do just
stay where the food is they don't care
about the males the males come and go
but but the males are on the periphery
fight human life what's the same thing
with all same thing it's the same thing
with
lions the males are fighting each other
and kicking each other out and the do
are just like whatever just do yeah the
do really don't care just whoever's the
most dominant male they'll allow they'll
allow yeah it's like they'll allow him
to breed but they don't need him right
you know
like like I said that's just like humans
it's like females like listen to this
all fem [__] you all do what you
want to do over there listen to this
[__] they don't really need you but they
don't really need yall have fun with
that [__] the center the center the
center of dear life are these females
and the babies there's like a big we're
the ones with WS [__] so it's like you
know the males are coming and going and
they're fighting and killing each other
sometimes DJ AM Maniac says holy [__]
you guys are still going I know man
[__] ridiculous 2 hours and 30
minutes it's like we we got to wrap this
[__] up we we haven't even like got
halfway through yeah okay you just keep
talking you just keep talking they're
they're all talking about deer and
thirsting after antlers and [__] right
they're talking about cat booty um poy
the cam
girl yeah they're talking about the
backstraps those are the Flaming yawn of
deer it shit's [__] beautiful it is
yeah yeah I'm a carnivore I'm not going
to like say that yeah Joy Joy saying
like 's explaining way all he can do is
focus on pooky's
butt yeah she does that [__] on
purp but yeah so so Bill rosstein calls
911 and says about the frozen body in
the [__] in his garage
right so this all goes now for a
while this case the frozen body in the
freezer and the bank robberry case were
separate like people didn't really like
uh relate them even though Bill rosin's
property was the one that the pizza guy
had got called to before this whole bomb
Shen against that happened
so there was some like inkling that it
was related but maybe
not hold on some person said that the
deer aren't safe to eat those parasites
in that's
[__] that's
[__] most of those deer aren't very
old old and I guess it probably depend
on where you are but if there were any
serious serious parasite infections good
Hunters know what to look for but no
there's it's it's not a
risk most of this [__] out here
especially in the south is just [__]
pristine [__] from nature and there
there isn't anything dangerous in those
deer I'd be more afraid to eat in some
of these [__] corporate [__]
cattle that come out of these [__]
weird [__] cattle Farms cuz uh
because of basically the steroids that
they give them you don't really know how
that hormonally can affect you they they
keep a lot of these an but the chickens
the same way and eat the [__] out of
that so who gives a [__] I guess none of
this food is perfect and know none of
this food is perfect honestly we have to
say like the chicken that we get from
Sam's it's like the breasts and stuff
are like freakishly large yeah yeah not
as bad as they used to be we always make
jokes about it when we're like taking
out of the package and like put in the
freezer I'm just like look at how fing
big this is it's like this is really we
probably shouldn't be eating it there's
a company we have down here called
Sanders and Farms chicken and
sanderson's Farms chicken
[__] has strange practices they have
strange labor practices too they were
hired a lot of illegal aliens there and
underpaying them they were working them
like slaves figures yeah and [__] ice
got on them and and and [__] sent
them all back this illegal this is this
illegal worker [__] [__] is not good
it's it's a modern-day version of
slavery basically yeah don't enslave
people that it's a type of slavery that
should not have to be said but
apparently it does because don't do that
some of these political parties have
vested interest in illegal aliens they
want them over here so they can [__]
work them like slaves all right and
that's got to
stop um you want legal people here and
you want [__] legal salaries and
[__] protections for these people
okay but Sanderson Farm was not finally
doing that they were [__] using lots
of steroids in chicken these [__]
chickens were growing to [__] bigger
than bigger than [__] normal like
bigger than a chicken could be and it
was happening within like a couple of
weeks from hatching that [__] ain't
normal they sent all these [__]
chicken breasts to Russia and Russia
sent them right back this was about six
years ago they were like no no no no no
they're like they're like that's not
that's not normal appar even the
Russians as crazy as they was like
that's not [__] normal send that [__]
back and after that happened I noticed
that wasn't six years it's more like
three years ago and my dad told me about
it because serson Farm is in
Mississippi you know where my f where
half of my dad family comes from so we
know how some of that [__] Works down
there my dad was making jokes about s's
Farms all right but the chicken serson
farm made a lot of damn chicken and a
lot of it got sold to [__] Sams too
and uh lately the chicken breasts have
been more like a normal chicken you
notice that they're smaller than they
used to be and there the texture is a
little better it was like eating
[__] I don't know man big old flaky
strips of [__] gelatin chicken it it
wasn't
normal large is what we're saying they
were using [__] a lot of hormones to
get those things to grow super super
[__] fast
well obviously who knows what that does
to
you yeah I don't know makes you grow
boobs yeah the Russians went nah I
already got boobs that is not a chicken
yeah but dudes might be worried about it
yeah it it the chickens were growing so
big and so fast that their legs were
breaking just from
walking yeah that's up that's that's a
bad
sign they said that my dad said that
they would see chickens they were
selling sanderson's Farms chickens at
discount on the [__] right on the on
the main road they were like 50 cents of
chicken yeah 50 cents of chicken but
every one of those chickens had broken
legs and it was because the chicken legs
were break too fat to like stand up they
were too fat and they got too they were
kind of odd tell like little tiny their
their legs were breaking before they
reach full maturity and [__] but they
were still [__] big those weak Hollow
ass bones and they were selling those
things for like 50 cents of chicken
somebody says how about that pink slime
yeah yeah for the chicken
yeah and the chicken McNuggets those are
still delicious
though they're still good
yeah some says I'm waiting for Tom to
say it I know a lot of people who have
ever eaten deer no one zombiie out yeah
I've eaten so many of them [__] deer
my dad my dad I got now I got to now now
you guys are talking me in to doing
impressions of my
dad ain't nothing wrong with him
deer
I've been eating them deer for 50
years that's good meat make good
Chell okay go ahead until well he's
lived how old is he now 75 all right
yeah he's been eating those there his
entire life so not 40 years his dad was
giving him those same deer when he was a
little kid so we said turkey necks yeah
you know turkey necks is good is filled
with turkey neck your dad is yeah that's
still every every time I think of your
dad I always think of
him you know American chicken's bigger
than Canadian yeah it's called roids man
steroids yeah not necessarily something
you want to eat it's like we eat it
sometimes but
yeah there it it's a little unsettling
to like buy a [__] thing of breasts
like chicken breasts from Sam's and like
the breasts are like three times bigger
than like what a normal chicken breast
like they're like [__] huge massive
it's like more than one person could eat
some and and what's weird is that
they've gotten smaller I remembered when
they were even bigger than that I
remember well a couple times we like
commented on freakish this [__] is it's
just like like like a small turkey
breast yeah
yeah it's [__] unreal it's weird man
it's like you got to eat but it's like I
know I don't know so all right so where
were we should we take a break if you're
ready to take a break man I sh peek go
ahead go ahead take a break all right so
we're going to put some like commercials
on commercials on CU we're already like
we're at 2 hours and 40 minutes yeah
Now's the Time to [__] go get a drink
got to like the main [__] yet if you
it's [__] ridiculous man it is it's
[__] ridiculous if you guys it's time
to go get go ahead and get a drink or
whatever go all right yeah I gota go to
the bathroom all right so we're gonna
like uh do some commercials and then
we'll be right
back join us September 25th 26th and
27th for a 3-day special streaming event
strange
realities to push the limits of your
reality featuring authors academics
researchers occultists experiencers
podcasters and
practitioners all presenting fresh
Cutting Edge material and resar SE Arch
streaming live featured presentations by
Brent Reign editor of alternate
perceptions magazine eron gulus host of
the saucer Life podcast David meta
writer and researcher Alan Green author
of Secret Cipher of the euphan Stephanie
Qui writer and blogger red pill junkie
14 researcher and Explorer Tim Bal host
of BAL of America guy Malone con class
and Troublemaker Timothy R post of
strange familiars DKI author and
practitioner GRE Bishop author of
project beta juny Ashford host of 13:00
reuse host of the farm jack Montgomery
folk magic Joshua cutchen author of
Thieves in the night Reverend Michael
Carter alien contact experiencer Dr
future host of Future Tony kale author
of Memphis hoodoo Ren Coller a cultist
Sarah as host of word to the road go
John tin ghost stalkers and hel all
three days only $20 tickets and info
available at Strang realities
conference.com brought to you by the
conspira normal podcast conspira normal
.c strange
[Music]
realities you love True Crime I love
True Crime and I've spent the last 3
years compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called called The Faceless
villain and volume 3 is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
caddy murders the Cary babies case the
Frog boys the alcasser murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
The Faceless villain volume 3 is an
involving exploration of Unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or ebook
formats on Amazon or download the audio
book version from audible.com and get
ready for a chilling journey through
Modern crime history
what you doing this morning
poy what you
doing hey tearing [__] up yeah tearing
[__] up
all yes what's going on what's going
on oh now you're going to
fit you had a bunch of Zoomies
earlier she running up and down running
up the cat
tree running
everywhere
yeah not now though
H now you decide to
do just going R the
camera you're silly you're silly I
know what you doing you going eat my
toes yeah she likes my
toes
yeah such a cute baby look at you at
your
Li she look evil there for a
second yeah
evil what's
up what's up yall mommy's desk yeah
you're just running all over the place
yeah what you doing what you
doing
yeah
3D cookie in
3D
yeah oh you're kind of stinky you run
around outside yeah getting all
sweaty she smells like Pooky
sweat just running around on the poor
skin sweaty she's kind
smells yeah you kind of smell it's all
right that's all right yeah you're such
a cutie pie yes you are you're such a
cutie
pie all
right yeah I I took that footage of
Pooky earlier today she was up in my
like I said earlier today she was
sleeping on my Mac over there and she
was like super into it drooling on my
[__] keyboard and everything thing
where did Tom go he went to like make me
another drink so are you using this
computer I must sleep on it yeah that's
basically what she does oh look at this
I let both cats out back oh [__] they're
outside okay oh you're in my chair now
we're we're switching give me that chair
oh I didn't know yeah I move M you move
that back there and I moved my see I
didn't realize I didn't realize what you
did there chair I didn't realize what
you did we don't have much room
okay what you did you messed up the
whole I made that this is all good you
messed up the whole
situation I took two videos of Pooky
earlier today doing her I wish I had got
cuz here's what I did she was zooming
around earlier she had Zoomies like this
morning when I got up and she was
running back and forth back and forth
and I tried to like videotape her and
then she stopped then she like just sat
down condescend it is looking at him
funny there you go I'm sorry if that's
freaking
YouTu I know it is kind of like
unsettling yeah so uh where was I so
like I
said so this body in the freezer case
and the bank robbery was initially you
all right yeah okay was initially not
connected okay even though Bill rosin
the dude with the body in the freezer
was basically the house where the pizza
delivery was sent to so some people were
like yeah maybe there's like some you
know some relation there but it's like
they weren't really like they thought
the two things were unrelated for a
while so then they break you all right
fighting it back man [__] you going
to be tequila monsters got me you're
going to be able to like get whole
[__] case because only we've really
only started to delve into this I'm
gonna [__] blame this [__] on [__]
KH vlon Oh I thought you were going to
blame it on me no no no I gotta blame it
on Mexico gotta blame that [__] on
Mexico I was gonna say usually I get
blamed this is Khan's people doing this
to me it's a [__] Mexican
[Music]
plot all right
so marjerie gets blamed for the body in
the freezer like I said but at first
they don't know initially if this had
had anything to do with the collar bomb
Pizza bomber
plant right even though it seems related
but they're not entirely
sure so all right Margery deal Armstrong
now once they arrest her for the murder
of the dude that's in the
freezer they kind of look a little bit
into her
past now this woman
like I said I'm going to show let me let
me show like a picture of her yeah I got
to see this I haven't seen this I forgot
I think I've seen her but I forgot what
she looks like hold on let me look well
she was like a good-look lady back in
the day cuz like look she's a beautiful
girl yeah I guess that's bill when he
was Bill looks like a [__] wolf
man looks like The Wolf Man Jack and
apparently the thing about Marjorie that
everyone said even though she had some
mental
illnesses was that she was very good at
getting people to do what she wanted to
do she was very um
manipulative she had some mental
illnesses uh she was variously described
as bipolar you know narcissistic
tendency she had like a a whole bunch of
different diagnosises over the years she
had like a hard time um keeping a job
[__] like that uh uh you know over the
years so she did actually have something
the matter with her but from an early
age she was like a very attractive woman
so she didn't have she didn't seem to
have like a lot of trouble getting dudes
to do what she wanted them to do she was
very good at
that
so what uh ended up happening
apparently was that over the
years she had apparently
allegedly killed a bunch of her
boyfriends and husbands would they do
that sometimes sometimes you got to I
mean sometimes you got
to dud you never know when you got to
knock a [__] they don't listen
they don't like [__] don't listen [__]
don't listen they don't [__] do the
laundry they don't [__] do what
they're supposed to do so sometimes you
got to like got to knock a [__]
off you got to knock them off just yeah
yeah well was money involved I'm just
saying yeah money involved money I don't
even like in her situation I don't even
think it was that I think she was just
like they were just annoying her so it's
just like that she got get rid of got to
get rid of a [__] well it'd be
much easier if this dude would just drop
dead so I'm going to like you know
process you wouldn't want to go through
the you wouldn't want to go through the
trouble of divorcing them or anything
exactly that's what I'm saying I I think
that was more her thing I don't think
she really got anything financially out
of it I think they just like annoyed her
so she was just kind of like well if
they would just die right now it would
be a lot more convenient she has too
much travel right I I I feel like that
was kind of like her
thing so she had actually
been uh brought to the public attention
in
1984 when she was 35 years old she was
actually charged with murdering a
boyfriend of hers named Robert
Thomas now she says that she shot the
dude in self-defense even though she
shot him six times while he was sleeping
[__] kept coming [__] kept coming at
her well okay he was sleeping right and
then he got up like that he started
coming at her and she's like P P PW PW
pow and he's like he's still waking up
and coming at her you know I mean well I
don't want to get too much into that
because here's the thing like a lot of
women are in abusive situations right so
it's like I don't want to get to the
thing where where it's like well they
don't want to like shoot the dude while
he's awake because they might like got
to be
Carle but while he's sleeping and like
you know where he sleeps maybe I should
kill him while he's sleeping so he can't
like do anything so I get that I get
that he's sitting there snoring and she
pow and then the [__] six times
yeah and then she shoots him and pow and
then times he snores again so she that
[__] not dead he didn't know was
coming he didn't know it was coming I
don't know I don't know
six times she shot him now she went to
trial for this like I said she was 35
years old and that was her boyfriend at
the time and uh she got off self-defense
because she claimed that he was abusive
and like that was the only time that she
could like get back at him got to
believe a woman so yeah well not always
honestly they don't always because
that's why a lot of women don't report
that [__] that's why a lot of women
don't report that [__] don't you believe
I've I've known women that that happened
to and they didn't report it because for
that very reason because they thought no
one believe them yeah okay so I'm just
saying I don't all right I feel
like I wouldn't report that [__]
murdered that [__] he Pro she
probably did but I mean he might have
been an [__] you don't know like I
said it's you know he he might have been
an [__] too that's what I'm saying
chances are they were both bad yeah I'm
not saying she's
awesome she's a horrible person but he
might have also been a horrible person
and I'm you know I'm just I'm just
saying so yeah so she shot him six times
in self-defense now she got
acquitted now four years after that
happened uh oh I got the
Rona four years after that happened [__]
I got you huh no I just something went
down the wrong way all right four years
after that happened uh she had married
in the interim to this dude named
Richard
Armstrong now he also
died let's call it l suspicious
circumstances he um apparently fell and
his head hit a coffee table
so that could have happened I'm not I'm
not saying that but how many times do
you have a [__] die in your
house around you though you know that's
what I mean I I feel like at this point
this
woman seems like
allegedly kill her I'm just saying I I
feel like she killed at least three of
her boyfriends or husbands I'm going to
be honest okay for what are you do what
are you doing with that weapon now oh
that's not a weapon that's just a tool
you going to stab me with it I cut that
box open with it remember but I'm just
going to be honest all
right imagine if you had a man all right
who said yeah I shot her she was abusive
she was sleeping I shot her and then
like a year a couple years later yeah
she fell yeah she fell that one fell
nobody's gonna believe that [__] well I
don't I feel like no one really believed
that [__] either it's kind of like that
cop who killed that cop that [__] he
was an old dude in his [__] 50s and
he's [__] marrying all these teenage
girls and they all end up dying remember
that [__] yeah yeah well I don't
know what happened to her she left she
left me I never seen her again I can't
imagine and like [__] five of them
left him yeah they left him all right
[__] you know when you kill somebody
they leave you don't see him again you
know fair enough I don't even think I
don't can and I don't ever think maybe
you guys could correct me you guys
probably know who it is I'm talking
about I don't think they ever got that
guy because he was a cop and he knew
about who thank you very much bro well
they get away with [__] and he he
understood the investigated
process and he was real cool under
questioning but he had like [__] five
of these like 18 19y old wives just kind
of [__] disappear and I feel like
that's kind of what happened in this
case like Marjorie deal
Armstrong look she had some mental
issues okay um that were probably
untreated but she also had a pattern of
her husband's SL boyfriends dying in
mysterious circumstances and I feel like
that was like not really looked into
so I feel like maybe a serial killer
because they interviewed
her uh for the Netflix documentary and
she for sure seems
like sadly she seems like a really
mentally ill person that didn't get all
the help that she needed because here's
the thing like a lot of people said when
she was growing up she was a beautiful
woman she was super super super
intelligent and a lot of people thought
that she was like going places but it
seems like mental illness kind of struck
her in her
20s and it didn't really get better from
there you know what I'm saying so I feel
like I don't know I I feel like I'm more
inclined to be sympathetic but also she
was kind of she she sucked she sucked
she was a terrible person okay you know
what I'm saying yeah um I know she had a
mental illness I know that
but she Justified killing these people
were they shitty to her
maybe but I question it I yeah I do feel
like I'm sure that dude who that cop
that killed all those [__] underage
girls was that he married [__] yeah
well they were they were mean to me yes
they were bad I'm sure that I don't bu
oh sure I'm sure they were bad from his
point of view she stopped wanting to put
they stopped wanting to put out or they
stopped loving him so he's like she's
bad know you're supposed to be my wife
and you don't care and you're trying to
leave you're bad so therefore I'm going
[__] kill you you know what I mean so
that's that's that's the type of person
that you're talking about you know you
you have this woman like oh well you
don't love me anymore you're leaving
you're bad I'm going to kill you so I'm
going to kill you yeah go like that's
your fault was this student abusive
maybe but yeah it could have been that
she was just perceiving that's what
that's usually what it is it could have
been that she was just perceiving she's
like [__] you don't love me [__]
you've this and that you're bad you lied
to me I'm going to [__] kill you and
then look what you made me do see if you
were a good person then I wouldn't then
that wouldn't happened that's how they
rationalize well that's what that's how
dudes do that's how women do well she
was doing that same [__] that's what I
mean so it's like you can't like forgive
it just see this some [__] that's what
dudes do when have you seen me do that
well no I'm just saying like it's not
what dudes do I'm not talking about you
it's just [__] it's [__] of
either sex
that's what they do I'm just saying it's
less likely for a woman to do that
because we don't really think like that
women don't give a [__] in women don't
think like that in general most women
are like well I'll just get another man
if I can't I'll get another man that's
well they're all the same to us you know
that's [__] so you're saying if me and
you broke up you just get another one
I'd be like that one you're like oh [__]
Tom [__] that [__] they're all
the same if they were all the same you'd
still be with that first
husband well they're all they're not all
the same that's man reason that's man
they're all like similar because they're
well they're
man it's like you have to they're men
when you're women are women are all
similar they're all women when you're a
woman you have to like be like well what
what amount of [__] am I willing to
put up with that's kind of like what you
have to deal with as a woman what amount
of [__] am I willing to put up with
me and every [__] on this
[__] Channel just going to [__]
we're just going to sit tight I ain't
going to say nothing me and every other
[__] out in the comments section
I'm just being truthful that's kind of
how we're approaching it and then in a
spock-like way okay how much like what
percentage of [__] do we have to
Bull do we have to deal with well that's
what guys are doing guys are doing exact
how much might be doing that too I'm
just saying that's what try I'm not
trying to start the Battle of the Sexes
okay but your average dude is like how
much [__] do I have to put up with
and how much that's exactly what we're
doing how much [__] exactly what
we're doing and how much money am I have
to spend to get that ass well that's
exactly what we're doing they were like
like how much is this going to be is
this going to be like on the first date
the second date the third date should I
take her to like a nice [__]
restaurant or should I just straight up
knock [__] boots on this [__] what
am I dealing with here that's what
they're [__] that's what that's
scheming but see the thing is that dudes
don't realize that I'm going get
women are doing the same thing women are
doing the same thing all right we are
always kind of like long as this [__]
opportunity in this like what is the
percentage of [__] have to deal it's
like you know to get whatever I want to
get whether it's dick or whether it's
whatever it is it's like how much
[__] am I going to have to deal with
to get that and then let's let's deal
with it it do some [__] so I feel well
no I feel like like I understand don't
know that no I understand women are
doing we're making the same calculations
I understand same calculations oh I
always knew that we're not I always knew
we're not dumb we're not I always knew
that it's it's all a [__] I
understood that it's all part of the
game right don't hate the player hate
the game exactly I understand exactly
understand and we're doing the same [__]
you guys I understand same [__] it's
almost time for me to get another drink
how far long are we on this case I don't
even know man God you keep like
interrupting okay keep stay on track
Jenny stay on track I don't even know
fcking yeah so this [__] margerie deal
Armstrong which if you guys saw this
documentary go watch it on Netflix if
you have it it's
fascinating she was like she seemed so
pretty back in the day and then like she
just went into crazy woman mode later
on so like I said she gets charged with
killing one of her ex boyfriends killing
one of her uh you know husbands
also so they arrest her for the murder
of the dude that was like found in the
freezer because Bill rosin has said that
is like she's the one that said like hey
I killed the dude I shot him with my
shotgun it's like then she asked me to
like put the dude in my [__] freezer
so I did Hernandez in there [__]
laughing about me saying knocking boots
I took him back to [__] 1991 on that
[__] that was some old school
[__] old school [__] I do know but I can
do that [__] man I time warped back to
91 and [__] pulled that one for it
was funny it was funny when I said
[Laughter]
it so all right so when they're
investigating the case back in
1984 even back in this time everybody I
feel like everybody involved in this
case is a hoarder yeah they're hoarders
nasty [__] look if you look at
like bottle [__] yeah well I
don't know if it's that bad but it's
almost because you you see like the
documentary and like all the people like
margery's house [__] Bill's house
they go in there with like the [__]
police cameras and [__] and it's
like look the house is like full of
garbage and it's like m
is there's just like not only do they
have bodies in the freezers like okay
that's bad enough but it's like also
Bill's got [__] piles of garbage
marjorie's got piles of garbage they
live like 10 miles apart all of these
people are hoarders and they're like
hanging out together so I
guess is that a thing like did they go
to like a group I don't know where
there's like a hoarder [__] internet
we're all hoarders and we're all going
to like hang out
together Mur people together and do like
a bank heist what is that about they all
they all found each other where they
were picking garbage cuz they go through
the goddamn garbage picking people's
garbage taking that [__] home [__]
you can go down the dump [__] see
there'd be hoarders at the [__] mouth
of the dump waiting for the trucks to
come in they're [__] taking [__] off
the trucks [__] taking that [__] home
although the weird thing saw that happen
before the relationship between Bill
ronstein and margorie D Armstrong is
very weird because I feel like I feel
like they they dated for a time in the
late 60s and early 70s and they were
like engaged to be married and then like
it didn't work out in the end but
apparently and according to a lot of
people that knew them um I feel like he
was kind of like obsessed with her and
he would do like anything that she said
which that's [__] crazy to me like if
somebody called me up like if some old
boyfriend friend called me up like from
10 years ago that I hadn't spoken to
called me up and said hey can you like
hide a body in your freezer I'd be like
yeah no yeah and then I would just hang
up these people probably didn't get much
action maybe not yeah so like oh you
again had hurt from you forever yeah
okay yeah bring it on over bring it on
over yeah yeah I se in FAL position
we'll put him in the fre it'll be fine
it'll be fine like I don't I don't
really put air freshen her above him and
everything it'll work out it'll work out
don't tell anybody
I don't like I'm get a Zinger hold on I
don't understand like the
[__] I don't understand the whole
reality around the situation I really
don't because look I've dated dudes in
the past it's like I can't imagine some
dude I dated like 10 years ago calling
me and saying hey can you hide a body
for me in your
freezer and me saying yeah like I don't
understand I don't see how that works
out but apparently he was so into her
because he had never married he had
never like dated another woman he had
never done anything like that look at
him bringing in cake so now I was going
to get cake actually you're elevating
the Zinger to the [__] level of cake
it's cake it's not a Zinger it's a cake
well but I didn't I didn't get a Zinger
I got a [__] oatmeal pie okay oatmeal
cookie pie you can have that look at
that he's going to eat it and he's
I need some
sugar go ahead like I don't understand
like how woman like she was hot back in
the day all right I'm going to say that
but when the at the time that this [__]
happened she was for real not hot enough
for this to have any well they had all
aged by that period right
but come on come
on if somebody like seriously all of you
guys somebody you
dated 5 years ago 10 years ago called
you and said I killed someone hide them
in your freezer how many of you would
say yeah okay nobody nobody there might
be one [__] out there that well
maybe one depend on how good he thought
that [__] was that would have some
really good I mean that so like magical
[__] they got dudes that are [__]
hard up that's like magical [__] right
there [__] had grip on it like velcro I
guess
yeah I guess yeah but like a lot of
people were like this dude was like
super into that and she called and she
was like old and like
[__] groy looking because like I said
she was like she was beautiful back in
the day but it's like she's like old at
this point she's like I'm I'm not
judging but it's like she looks like
super n good and she calls him and she's
like look I killed my boyfriend put him
in your freezer and he was like
okay I I can't I can't picture any
situation where that would be okay I
just can't for a second I thought we
were doing this episode from Bombay
Beach did you be awesome would it Bombay
Beach down [__] Sal and sea in
California side of the [__] American
apocalypse
that's an evil place it's like some kind
of Fallout it'd be cool if we were doing
a show from there we should one of these
days Art Bell would do that [__] from
out in the middle of the desert we need
to [__] do that [__] from Bombay
Beach go look up Bombay Beach people on
YouTube Bombay Beach [__] salt salt
and sea that's an amazing well they made
a movie a couple years my dad used to
take me there when my dad used to take
me there when we lived in
California it was good then now it's
just like [__] something out of
Fallout well yeah there's nothing there
it's like one big old [__] biohazard
rotten fish yeah yeah yeah so all right
so they bring margerie in for the murder
of her boyfriend who is found in the
freezer yeah Duke gtic angel
said those those oatmeal cookie those
oatmeal cookie pies are like crack of
the snack world yes they are yes they
are it's like crap I like them though I
don't like them I like them they're
super sweet sweet and chewy sweet and
chewy like I said I'm into like the
zebra cakes or swiss cake rolls are good
too saying that's a snapper
okay so they bring margerie deal
Armstrong into custody for this one
freezer murder at at this point they
don't think she has anything to do with
the bank robbery so they bring her
in now she says she doesn't have
anything to do with the people Pizza
bomber case right um she says that she
kind of knew about it but I feel like
she kind of like
strung that was a quick that's a quick
advertisement oatmeal cream pie little
Debbies that's a plug go ahead she kind
of like strung uh the investigators
along she's like yeah I kind of know
about this dead body that was in the
freezer but also I kind of maybe know
about that like whole like Bai bummer
thing but not so it's like she was kind
of like do she was very good at
like manipulating the legal system as in
she would only say things that were um
you know that would get her certain
things that would get her certain
privileges but she wouldn't say any more
than that she was really good at
manipulating the system like to her
Advantage although like I said she she's
dead now
so yeah so she said
that uh she initially said she didn't
know anything about the plot she said
that well I knew the dude that was in
the freezer but I killed him because it
was selfdefense he was abusive or
whatever and it's like she's like well I
kind of knew about the plot in the sense
that I supplied the kitchen timers for
the bombs but I didn't know anything
about it um you know
other than
that and she's like I also here was
another thing too that she did because a
lot of witnesses said that they had seen
her and Bill rosin who was very
distinctive because of his [__] habit
of wearing uh overalls all the time he
was an Elmer he was a little bit of an
Elmer he was an Elmer and a lot of
people had said that they saw both of
them call
for the pizza delivery like from a a
foam booth at a gas station like near
the house so they had like a bunch of
witnesses that had seen that so she
initially denied knowing anything about
it and then when all these Witnesses
came out they said hey we saw you and
the do and the overalls and like you
were at the [__] you know phone booth
like when the [__] uh pizza delivery
call was made so then she said yeah I
was there but it's like I didn't really
have anything to do with so she like
every story she told was
like every time some new news came out
she would change the [__] story you
know what I'm saying that mean she was
lying uh that's what I'm saying I I feel
like I mean she's dead now so it's like
she died in uh
2017 okay of cancer she had breast
cancer all right she died in prison so
it's like I'm not she's not going to sue
me or anything like that because that
was her thing that was how she made all
of her money this is I was telling him
this earlier like when we went to the um
when we went to the post office I was
like I'm reading about this case these
[__]
backwoods
Pennsylvania rednecks pretty
much um they had all kind of
money in the bank apparently or this is
something we were marveling at they had
a lot of money where do you like how do
you get that kind of money and hold on
to it living like that dude I have like
$1,000 in my bank account and maybe and
that's it that's it yeah they had
[__] gone I'm starving they had
hundreds of
thousands how does that happen yeah how
does that happen I don't know they have
a pot to piss in really when you think
about and like all of them were living
like living like poppers Porters like
they're like their houses were like just
full of like crap and garbage and stuff
and it's like how do these people have
$100,000 they had a way of weaseling
money and squirreling it away and yeah I
don't know there's some people that just
have the ability to [__] squirrel
away money and make money multiply a
little bit they just keep squirreling it
away and squirreling it away I guess and
they're just real cheap they don't spend
money on anything it only goes in it
doesn't go out that's the only thing I
can think of uh they don't buy anything
I mean like we buy stuff you know I
don't think they bought anything I mean
I don't buy a lot of stuff other than
[__] to do with the show yeah clothes
every now and then uh bills that's not
really buying things like that's what I
mean I pay bills I buy food I buy [__]
for the show like microphones and like
yeah books to review they just had ways
they had ways of cheaping getting used
[__] I guess and buying real find
stumbling into real cheap [__] [__] and
just yeah I'm going to use that and
wearing free clothes when you when you
looked at them it looked like they were
clothes they got for free out of a bag
it's like it always bothers me like
every time like I see Unsolved Mysteries
like from back in the day and like
here's like some [__] um you know no
I'm not hating but like some
[__] rednecks
from wherever it's a southerner talking
about rednecks ain't that something but
there there is it is true it is true it
is true I mean yeah and like they and
they have like and then it's like oh
they disappear whatever and then they
left like a [__] you know uh they
left a house they left like an estate
that's worth like several hundred, I'm
like how the [__] did that happen how
did you guys get
$100,000,000 being real Frugal over a
long period of time letting money was
coming in but it wasn't going
out you know they were [__] dude I
have never they were buying and wearing
and [__] that you wouldn't know cuz they
get it for free never ever had more than
$2,500 in my bank account at one time
I've never ever had more than that it's
cuz you're poor I know
ever and like I saying nothing I've had
a pretty good old people these old
people it's like these people that are
like oh it's like they like [__] them
out of like $100,000 like where the [__]
did you get
$100,000 where' you
where can I get $100,000 funny thing is
is that you know what I mean that' be
nice I've come into [__] I've come
into pretty good [__] lumps of
[__] cash at one time before but the
funny thing about it is is that was
happening when I was young and I was
really [__] high roll and in Boston
all right not everything I did was
[__] totally on the up and up in that
time sometimes you come across a big old
[__] chunk of change you know what I
mean wheeling and dealing with other
salesmen I was [__] hanging out with
a bunch of corporate salesmen we used to
do all kinds of [__] that was kind of
like like little crooked you know I mean
a little bit you know kind of against
company policy but other guys did it and
fcking weird [__] those companies are
gone now though it doesn't really matter
all right and [__] you know what I
mean hey man [__] we could do this
and that with this old equipment blah
blah blah we know we have a customer
here we could sell this [__] man why are
we throwing it away that kind of [__]
you know I mean they're like well we'll
close this deal but hey if you [__]
I'll tell you what you help me move this
[__] down here and you don't [__] you
keep this between me and you this is
[__] sick grand for you right we'll
divide it this way so there's a bunch of
[__] like that going on and it happens a
lot in in corporations that have access
to material that can be sold in a
[__] customer database if you have
that you can do a lot and the company
won't know about it okay just watch
alien 2 you remember that mother that
Burke [__] remember that Burke
from Alien 2 [__] hey we could come
out of this and me and that [__] was
just the way you made money well yeah
that's the [__] that you in the new
much conscience I guess you get too much
conscience in the [__] new I'm too
good a person in the world of New
England business Boston New York and
[__] like that that's how you did [__]
all right it was semi gangster stuff
crooked you know what I mean but that's
just the way it was and that's how guys
moved up because the companies that you
work for you know are not going to be
they're not monoliths they're not going
to be around forever and the guys above
you got above you and they made their
[__] doing kind of
back back backyard you know back room
kind of deals you know what I mean I am
under the that everyone that's rich but
this is what I'm going to try to tell
you I didn't get to the [__] point
the faster you make that
[__] the faster you spend it because it
was like an easy come easy go like whoa
whoa look at yeah what we score score
you know what I mean then what did you
do you went right down on the [__]
club and you spent that [__] on booze
yeah and [__] buying Boo for other
people and [__] hooking up with
[__] women and that's girls and and
then you're [__] going to go and
you'd run through that [__] a period of
about two months and you're like and
you're like oh no I'll do it again yeah
because you kind of have this casino
mentality like you're in Las Vegas see I
would never I'll just do it again you
know mean I never do that because I
didn't grow up like that yeah I grew up
in a [__] tril Park yeah well that's
not how the world really is that's only
one aspect it's like when I have $100 I
hang on to that [__] with my dear life
that's not that's that's only one aspect
of reality there are other realities in
the world you yeah but I don't know
those realities because I did not live
those reality right there are other real
I whenever I get money I hang on to it I
don't like to buy [__] I don't like to
even buy [__] I
need yeah that's true I mean I got to
get her to buy [__] all the time it's
like no you got to you I need new shoes
yeah I put it off as long as I feel like
a goddamn vet sometimes I'm like no we
time for you to go shopping you know
what I mean [__] yeah but there's no
reason no reason to let the listeners
know about these [__] problems though
we got to get this show
done we got to get this show done you're
talking about what you need to buy are
you letting me are you letting go ahead
all right go ahead so where was it this
like a 4 Hour show man well we're
already at 3 hours and 19 [__] yeah well
that's on you that's on you is it you're
going to blame me okay go ahead
oh I'm [__] fell your [__] fell yeah got
I got it now yeah so they bring margerie
in on the murder charge of the dude
that's in the freezer obviously because
bill says hey she told she shot the dude
and put him in the freezer so they bring
her in and she's like the first thing
she says pretty much is that I'm not
involved in that bomb that collar bomb
[__]
um but she did admit later that she was
within a mile of where the bomb plot
happened because several witnesses she
didn't say that at first but she said
that later like after Witnesses said hey
um when we were driving past this gas
station with this phone booth on the day
that the bomb [__] happened like the the
bank heist they're like we saw you and
the tall dude in the overalls we saw you
at the phone booth like calling for the
pizza and we saw you guys that day so
obviously she couldn't deny being a part
of the plot but she just like basically
said yeah I was there but there was
other reasons so it's like every time
new [__] information came out she
would like come out with some other
[__] now it came to light later that
maybe she had masterminded the whole
situation I'm not really I think it was
between her and Bill honestly what it
you look like you're about to like ponti
no I'm listening to what they [__]
say go ahead what are you talking about
no I don't want to get Sidetrack they're
asking me about stealing people's
girlfriends down in New York I think I
know what he's talking about what are
you talking about I was drunk at the
time I [__] probably L some [__] slit
probably he's probably I don't know
exactly what he's talking about cuz
there were several of them that I stole
but I think I think when you talking
about New York he's talking about he's
talking about Paul Bearer Paul Bear's
girlfriend for [__] from [__]
sheer Terror that's what he's talking
about I'll go ahead I think that's what
he's talking about I already told that
story man I ain't G to tell it again
you're stealing people's girlfriend that
was a long time
ago that [__] is still probably
trying to beat my ass over that
girl I doubt it after all it's hard to
say after all her name was Lisa
although are very sensitive and they
will like carry a grudge for he was a
guy he was a guy from a band called
sheer Terror I stole his girlfriend he
was yeah and he caught me eventually did
you really still yeah they were living
together and I was [__] hitting it oh
they were still living together I was
creeping around with her she was
cheating on him and [__] I'd call
over there every now and then he'd pick
up a phone by accident because I didn't
realize he was I thought he was I
thought he wasn't going to be there at
the time [__] I had to talk my way
out of that one [__] it's just some
weird [__] then finally that [__]
[__] seems like a lot of
trouble that [__] was good though man I
was fresh out of the army she was cute
man she was [__] cute yeah cute I
couldn't say no to that man come on what
are you talking about I was like 24 I'm
just I'm gonna [__] do what the
hormones tell me to do
25 wow she was cute she about 22
21 stop it stop asking me these
questions you're trying to get a good
show out of me we're doing a good show I
don't need to [__] tell these stories
dud are so funny that dude sent every
dude he knew out after me to try to whip
my ass that was [__] down a place
called the wrath scalar was like this
Punk Rock Bar Boston called the wrath
scalar a lot of punk rock bands used to
play there Sex Pistols played there when
they came
through Ramones used to play there back
in the day it's gone now well yeah that
was down Kenmore Square I think it was
Kenmore Square if I remember correctly
where you got off Kenmore station
it's been a long time it's over there
near fed
away yeah I remember that [__] I
remember that [__]
yeah you kind of he likes to tell people
that he stole me from my ex I did steal
you from your ex ex kind but I was going
to leave anyway yeah it was the time it
was time I was going to leave anyway you
were just there you never cheated on him
though you you you broke up with him
yeah I did yeah I wouldn't do that I'm
not an Al yeah you broke up with him
yeah I'm not an [__] I would I
wouldn't do that yeah Lisa wouldn't like
that though she was living with him she
was living with him and she was trying
to cut it loose but she was kind of
scared of
him yeah so she she didn't really want
to bre but like I said I I wouldn't do
that she got caught though we both got
caught but not directly the word got out
then they [__] had a big fight he
left he went back to New York I think
that's what he's talking about let me
see I was bad man you were you were tell
[__] bad you were terrible person
[Laughter]
yeah they're saying I was a soncho
you're [__] right I was a soncho man
[__] s he's the worst seriously
yeah honestly like when I first started
going out with you like hanging out with
you we got a sheer ter you know how many
people warned me against you
yeah they warned me against you yeah
[__] Paul
Paul the lead singer of sh Terror
[__] that was that was another that
was another time it's another time see
I'm just on a [__] podcast as the
comedic relief this is actually Jenny's
show but I'm just [__] you know what
I mean I help conceive this [__] I'm
actually the clown of this show but my
[__] story goes way back it goes way
back I know a lot of [__] people all
right but this is how you do it now you
do the [__] through [__] social media
I was trained as an actor but as soon in
high school I had a real good Drama
teacher and some of the people that I
came that I came up with like Marilyn
rice cub and
[__] [__] what's her name and they
ended on to have a [__] yeah I'm
trying to
F Parker posie there you go Parker posie
which that's not her name but [__] I
was friends with her and her brother and
[__] from Mississippi and anyway they uh
they all went on to have Hollywood
careers but I didn't want anything to do
with that I joined the army I I loved I
I was was actually I ain't going to
[__] brag or anything but [__] I
was an excellent actor could sing and
[__] did did musicals but I knew how
[__] I didn't like those people real
corrupt all that [__] Casting Couch
[__] [__] they would have tried to
Tom Cru my ass I end up and [__]
ended up in [__] Scientology or some
[__] like that [__] somebody would
have put something in your butt trying
to put [__] in my [__] ass and [__]
[__] me and Cory Feldman and [__] you
know what I mean Fu it's just I I a get
involved in that [__] well some people
want that but most people I didn't want
to have a pretend life I wanted to have
a real life you know what I mean so I
went up and had [__] fun and
Adventure [__] joining the armies and
[__] coming out [__] becoming in
[__] corporate salesman and [__]
weird [__] I you know I saw culture guys
kind of [__] woke me up about certain
[__] just things weren't as they
appeared and just life was interesting
just had fun you know and uh
then there was a Gulf War and then
[__] you know I kind of did some
contract work through [__] law
enforcement military type stuff and then
uh retire from that and [__] you know
I'm [__] and then I met you and messed
everything up no I no it's all good I'm
[__] you know I'm I'm I'm a retired
veteran you know they still pay me and
[__] you know so it's all I'm all having
fun having fun on the show actually
technology caught up with me this is the
kind of [__] that I actually wanted to
do even back then I'm like I said I'm
very excited about this [__] because
this is what I wanted all it's like look
I can like not actually talk to people
but talk to people like I don't have to
like talk to people on the phone or like
talk to and there's nobody controlling
us or anything we don't really have
bosses yeah awes that's awesome I love
it yeah it's our own ship we can do
whatever we
want yeah
so
Marjorie um gets accused of
masterminding the whole entire uh you
know bank heist type of
[__] like I said they thought that she
had probably killed a couple of her
boyfriends and maybe a couple of her
husbands earlier
on so uh so they think that well the
thing about it though they arrest
her and she initially if you've seen
like the Netflix documentary she
basically even up and she's dead now she
died in
2017 she basically points the finger at
Bill Roth and says that he's the one
that masterminded the whole thing now I
will admit that the FBI profile of the
person that masterminded this whole
plot does match Bill rothin better than
it matches her I will say
that but I do think that she was
involved from the get-go I do think that
her and Bill rosin got together I think
he was the one that built the bomb I
think he was the one that wrote the
letters I think he was the one that did
all that [__] and she was just like in
on it from the beginning what are you
are why you worried about what I'm doing
because you're like weird [__] because I
[__] heard read what they said and I
was thinking about it but I can't I
don't want to interrupt go ahead okay go
ahead I'm reacting to what they're
saying oh okay okay you want me to
[__] say somebody said why is it that
all [__] ghosts speak English English
is the international language of ghosts
okay but it no uh [__] you would think
that CH would be the international
language no the the language of the
internet is [__] English so the
language of the [__] spirit world is
going to be English no it's not uh when
I was in Brazil [__] I had friends uh
Brazilian friends who as kids said that
they heard [__] ghostly voices they
were you know in one one particular case
that I remember I kind of believed him
cuz I was there at the
time we were in a [__] house it was
his
house but his dad had died a few months
before and he was sitting there playing
electric guitar he was about 17 at the
time and we smelled this [__] smell
of burning candles coming out of nowhere
and he got [__] scared and stood up
and started running to the door and he
he swore that he heard his father's
voice I didn't hear it but he said he
heard it and and it was in
Portuguese
that's pretty creepy yeah and it was
like and his father's and it was just
his father's voice saying just something
random you I mean like a conversation
that he was having a long time ago and
it kind of sounded like it was distant
but the smell of [__] burning candles
and [__] in in Brazilian culture might
be associated with
makumba because you know they leave out
burning candle offerings and [__] yeah
yeah but uh go ahead all right so
Marjorie like I said initially she
denied having anything to do with the
plot but later she said she had like
information about it but the thing about
it is that she said she had information
about it because she wanted to get like
moved to a different
prison but she did admit that she had
killed her boyfriend James rhen by
shooting him but that it was in
self-defense so in late 2005 this is uh
a few months after margerie deal
Armstrong uh first talked to the
feds they get another uh break in the
case so some other witness came forward
and said that they uh that there was
this extelevision repair man I believe
this is Ken
Barnes who came forward he was a crack
dealer and he uh was also allegedly
involved in this whole entire plot now
he had been a fishing buddy of uh marger
de Armstrong and apparently he was in on
the
[__] now he was like in prison on
unrelated drug charges at the time the
Sol [__] was going down his
brother-in-law had turned him in so he
got threatened with more time behind a
bars and he decided that he was going to
like talk so he said look I'll just tell
you everything that happened like if you
give me a a later sentence so that was
agreed
to now he said that margorie deal
Armstrong was The Mastermind behind the
collar bomb
murders he said that the whole reason
that she had done this [__] was because
she wanted her
father
killed now she wanted her father killed
because she thought not that he was
spending her inheritance on [__]
like he was giving it to Charities and
[__] like that instead of like just
dying and giving it to her like she
thought was supposed to happen so she
was like upset about
it so she decided she was going to like
speed up the process by having him
killed so
allegedly she paid to have Kenneth
Barnes um kill her kill her
father now she didn't have enough money
to do that which is the whole reason why
allegedly the whole bank heist plot
happened right because she needed to get
money to have to pay the Hitman to kill
her dad so she could get the money now
as of the Netflix documentary I don't
know about nowadays but as of the
Netflix documentary the dad was still
alive live and they kind of asked him
like the dude he like lives in this you
know modest house in wherever
Pennsylvania and apparently he had he's
like a
millionaire and he's like yeah I was
giving her money for a while until I
realized that she was like mentally ill
and I was like enabling and it's like so
I stopped doing it and he has like over
a million dollars which how the [__] do
people get this money I don't really
know I don't I don't know but he had it
so she was mad that he wasn't dying
quick enough and she wasn't getting the
inheritance so she was going to have him
murdered and she needed money to have
him murdered so that's why she did the
bank thing I'm not sure if I entirely
buy that but that's what the story is
you know what I'm saying what are you
what are you thinking not thinking about
anything you're not thinking about
anything M just listening to this story
just trying to figure out where this is
going to go well I know where this is
going to go I know where this is going
to go yeah you know where it's going to
go basically she's allegedly she's
feeling like well the dad is like giving
money away it's like that's money that
could be going to me he keeps giving
that money away and I won't have nothing
left I w't have anything left to inherit
so I need to knock knock motherucker off
and I don't have enough money to knock
him off right so I'm going to do
this elaborate
bank heist I wonder why he was given all
that money away was he crazy or he
didn't want her to have it he did not
seem
well from what I could determine from
the interviews that were done in the uh
in the uh
documentary he seemed perfectly Lucid um
I think he did not want her to have the
money got to be cuz you don't do that to
your flesh and blood he knew that she
was [__] nut not right yeah he he
knew she was nut he want her to have
that he was not like just giving the
money away willy-nilly he was giving it
away to like Charities and stuff like
that that's the same as willy-nilly no
it's Charities are most Charities that
he believed in and [__] like that so
it's like he did not think that she was
capable
of I mean he knew from a very early age
that she was not right Charities are
fake people just kind of giving you the
wakeup call maybe they only have to give
like 1% to the cause the rest of that
[__] they care they [__] right but
like I feel like if he would have given
it to her would that she had done
something bad with it that's what I mean
would that have been better that's how
he was doing it not I don't think so
yeah because I feel like she was
probably a Sero kill because allegedly
Charities are scams though people don't
give your money to charity not all of
them not all of them I think almost
everybody I know that was involved in
one was a [__] scam artist they only
have to give they only have to give 1%
depending on what state it is each state
has a slightly different law about how
much and remember in the Northeast
because there were some guys that I knew
that [__] ran telemarketing companies
also did police charity [__] scams
well everybody knows that's a yeah the
police but that was back when those were
new you know what I mean there's other
ways they would just th that same group
of dudes just drifted from one [__]
scam to the next they made money they
were all legal you know what I mean it's
legal but just cuz something legal I
don't mean it's [__] moral that [__]
[__] scabs it's [__] hilarious I
think and and they're totally uh feel
totally good about it they're like well
these people want to feel good by giving
money away as to their cause so they can
feel good about themselves and that's
what they're getting when they give us
money because they took almost all of
that [__] although would it have been
better for him to give like the money to
this woman that was allegedly a seral
killer no but it would he should have
given it directly to a person that could
have done something good with it that's
what I would have
done yeah I wouldn't even given that
[__] to an orphanage because they'd
steal it
too well I'd find an IND yeah most of
them are [__] scams also [__]
especially if it's owned by a
church well I wouldn't give anything to
church related [__] yeah is about the
same [__] okay you know how I feel about
that I would I would have chose a
[__] worthy but needy person and
given them all [__] money well yeah
that well that seems like she was like
she wanted the dad to give her all the
money yeah and the fact that he wasn't
giving her all the money was making her
mad so she decided she was going
allegedly that she was going to pay
someone to kill him so she could get the
money that was that was allegedly the
reason behind the the whole like bank
heist is she was trying to get the money
$250,000 which was going to be used to
pay the Hitman that was going to kill
the dad and then she was going to get
the inheritance that's what the whole
alleged situation
was so
2006 um federal agents meet with margro
deal
Armstrong now they said
at this stage and this is um you know
three years after the bank
robbery they said look we have enough uh
evidence to you know bring against you
not only for the murder of the boyfriend
which was in the freezer but also for
this
[__] so she freaks out um she starts
like slamming her fist on the [__]
table and whatnot like and she's like I
don't have have anything to do with that
I don't have anything to do with that
and she is
like even though people have seen her at
the
site the [__] uh phone booth where
the [__] uh call to the pizza place
was
made they've seen her there several
multiple Witnesses have seen her at this
[__] phone booth but she's still
trying to deny that she'd had anything
to do with this [__]
[__] so July 2007 this is the 4ye
anniversary of the uh you know the
heist so the US attorney's office um
calls a news conference and they say
that
um sh you all right I lost my place I
lost my
place this is why I don't like doing
[__] live this well you talking about
you love doing [__] live you were
telling me you love to do [__] it's all
that [__] this is you're on your
[__] like basically your sixth or
seventh drink this is like a [__]
this is like a marathon show you and you
drink so much it's not even [__]
funny and I've been working all day yeah
and I've been working all day it's
Saturday but I've been working all day
well look man we got the the show's
going long I mean is there any way to
[__] like a bridge this and cut to
the [__] chase it don't really need
every damn detail of the damn of what
went with the case we know she got
caught what happened at the
trial all right so what happened to the
so they eventually what ended up
happening was that they put her in
prison they put her in a mental Asylum
for a while yeah but eventually she
ended up getting life in prison now okay
um Bill rosin he also got convicted but
he died died of cancer before they could
like put him in prison for anything now
some people have um speculated and I'm
kind of leaning toward this as well that
bill rosin was maybe the Mastermind
behind the soul [__] because if you read
the
letters what they did was they probably
typed the
[__] like on a typewriter and then re
traced it with uh you know with human
[__] pens and [__] so it didn't look
like but the fact that the way that it
was written the way that it was that
sounded like Bill rosin they're all in
there going you can do it Jenny you they
say Jenny's faded as
[__] it's a everybody's laughing this is
what seriously this is my life I have to
every topic that we do I can't count on
him to know anything about it I have to
know everything about
it and I can't just be like yeah I don't
know I don't know I can't do that I have
to like [__] be thank you Ken thank
you look there you go thanks Ken so
here's the thing I feel like Okay so
Marjorie she was a genius okay I get
that but I feel like maybe Bill
Rothstein even though when they brought
him in for questioning if you see the
[__] you watch the documentary on
Netflix they bring him in like for the
questioning and [__] and he seems like a
normal dude and he seems like not
sketchy yeah but I feel like he's may be
sketchy but I feel like you know what
I'm saying I feel like he's the
one so you're putting it on him you're
not put her well no I no I'm not saying
that like I oh she knew about it she
knew so what what were they trying to
they they just wanted to get him down
there to rob that bank and get the
[__] money okay here's what I think
happened and I don't know if this is
what actually happened I feel like
Marjorie yeah and Bill yeah like Bill
was the dude like he he came up with all
technical [__] right he fit the FBI
profile yeah of the bomber okay like he
was kind of like he made the bombs and
did all that [__] he made he had the
technical knowledge to make the bombs he
like was into the whole like oh I'm
going to send him on a scavenger hunt
and I'm going to do this and that and
the other like I feel like he was the
dude that could like send the police off
and like what was the idea behind
scavenger hunt do you think to buy time
to get killed throw off but I honestly
feel like if Bill rothin had been the
one that masterminded this which I kind
of I'm leaning toward that all right I
kind of feel like he wanted
to make it seem like he was smarter than
everyone yeah and because here's the
thing he was like a really smart person
yeah and I feel like he didn't um live
up to the expectations yeah you know
what I mean that people were like you
know expect he felt like he didn't
[__] live up this [__] so he's trying
to [__] he's reaching far he's trying
to make this master CRI right so he's
like I'm going to make this master crime
what was what was the point of what do
you think the point of the [__]
scavenger hunt was so he wasn't being
tailed so they no I don't think so I
think that whole [__] yeah there's like
oh you can do because the the cops did
the [__] like the the letter that said
that you can do this that and the other
like to like Defuse The Bomb like the
cops did that and there's like yeah
there's no way they could have he could
have done that in time yeah to like
diffuse the bomb so I feel
like I feel like Brian Wells the dude
that blew up yeah I feel like he
probably knew about the
crime in a general sense in that we were
going to like you know rob a bank and he
was just like okay that's fine I'm going
to get some money out of it and he was
like cool with that I wonder if he knew
that the bomb was really going to blow
up I feel like he did not because I feel
you think he knew about the scavenger
hunt I don't know because I feel like
here's the thing Brian Wells is really
into like scavenger hunt you think they
intended him to blow
up they did yeah yes so they were just
trying to get get rid of a witness yes
yeah okay it makes more sense I but I
don't feel like Brian Wells knew knew
that that that was I feel like the
original plan that they told him yeah is
what he thought was going to Happ was
that we are going to strap a fake bomb
on you right and we're going to like rob
a bank and we're going to make all this
money and blah blah blah and he's like
yeah that sounds cool and then like when
he gets there they're just kind of like
guess what it's a real bomb yeah do it
and he and here's another thing it make
it makes sense when you look at it that
way of why they put a real bomb in him
they had to put a real bomb on him
because he would have lived if they
didn't right had he lived he would have
told them who put the [__] bomb on
him so they put a real bomb on him and
killed him to eliminate him as a witness
when they were very [__] Lucky in a
way they were lucky that he didn't spill
the beans before the bomb went off but I
guess maybe he didn't think the bomb
really was going off or he would have
said hey I know who put this on me I'm
gonna tell you because I'm gonna die in
minutes I'm gonna tell you who did this
to me honestly I think until the beeping
started because if you watch the video
it's beep beep I think until that
started I don't think he realized that
it was really going to blow up or maybe
he suspected that it might really blow
up but because if you watch the video of
him like in the bank like where he's
stealing the
money I mean he's
very casual he's like hey I'm gonna stti
I'm going to take a I had that on like
if you really thought that there was a
bomb around you that was going to blow
up yeah I feel like you wouldn't be
acting that casual yeah I was I feel
like he kind of thought like maybe it
wasn't really going to happen but then
like when it started beeping because he
didn't freak out and until it started
going
beep like it was really going to [__]
blow up and then he started like being
like oh [__] yeah maybe this is really
good because I feel like they he might
have thought that was added drama though
because I feel like I'm not saying that
you know I'm not saying that he didn't
know about it like ahead of time because
I think he probably did know about we're
going to rob a bank but I don't think
that he knew that a live bomb
was G to be strapped as I sorry I don't
think that he knew that I was watching
that [__] pretty much live I felt sorry
for the dude he's like you better get
the bomb squad here this thing's going
to go off yeah and they're like you just
stay right there and they got him on the
front of the car you just stay back
right back there and he goes hey you
need to get the bomb squad here this
thing's really going to go off it blew
up it blew up boom it didn't really blow
up it was like a shotgun blast well like
I said it was like it wasn't it was like
a um like a handcuff thing what they
call a hot shot yeah it was like that it
blew a hole in his chest it didn't blow
his head off it's about like a shotgun
cartridge it just went off it was it was
here and it's just like uh it takes a
while to get a [__] bomb squad out
but I'm not sure they actually had a
bomb squad coming they probably did they
probably did they arrived three minutes
after he blew up yeah they wouldn't have
enough time they were on the way yeah
they just like the the nearest bomb
squad was yeah they wouldn't have had
enough time they wouldn't have had
enough time it's it's sad because I feel
like that dude and I feel like for four
years I think that's what that all I
think that's what all that all that
[__] scavenger hunt was all about is
to [__] soak up all that time so
there was no way he could get out of it
without getting killed well like I said
the police you think you would just make
the timer shorter it it doesn't really
make sense well the police did it
afterward like what ostensibly what was
supposed to happen was that he was
supposed suppos to rob the bank and then
he was supposed to go to the McDonald's
and get more instructions and then he
was supposed to go to another place that
was supposed to give him another key
that was supposed to like prolong the
time on the bomb and it's like I feel
like the cops did that [__] and they
were just like yeah well there was no
way it wouldn't have worked that he
could have done it in time did the key
thing work about giving more time it was
it was all just a ruse so it was all a
ruse I feel like they intended him to
die from the outset but he didn't know
that right which is had to be which to
me is very sad because I feel like like
I said they they showed like footage of
him in the bank and he seemed like all
casual about it like I'm like my head's
not going to blow
up so some people have said that oh that
that means that like he was in on it I
think he was in on it to an extent but I
don't think he was in on it to the
extent that they're going to blow my
[__] head off I like
seriously you know what I'm saying yeah
they're they're laughing they're say
you're GNA make it
Jenny they're saying three atom's three
three three Tom's drinks that's like six
or seven yeah those things are [__]
strong there's like that much [__]
put this put the uh put the thing up
there's like that much [__] vodka in
each one of hers wait is that the third
one that's the third one yeah that's a
lot that's like drinking six or seven
drinks and mine was like five
drinks M mine was like five drinks I had
that [__] up to there that much [__]
uh uh what do you call it tequila so it
puts a dent in the fifth that I'm
pouring when I when I pour it in there
we because I don't want to [__] go
out there and make more drinks and that
you know that was the mixer
so but uh this pretty much yet so she
died in prison of cancer what happened
to him um well she he got blown up no
but but her her accomplish though what
Happ um he died uh of cancer even before
he got brought to trial like honestly he
died in 2014 like he some people
speculate that because he might have
been he might have known that he was
dying of cancer beforehand was like the
reason why he was doing right wa because
died he even got like now Ken Burns who
was another uh accomplice of the [__] he
died in uh last year 2019 he was in
prison but like I said he might be
thinking hey man I'll do this [__]
bank robbery and I have enough money to
cure my cancer if I get away with it but
he'd be tripping because [__] it
takes a [__] hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of dollars to cure you Ser
okay he probably just wanted to have a
good time before he died I kind of feel
like look margerie deal Armstrong
was a lunatic okay she was a
lunatic she um unfortunately she had a
lot of mental problems she was like
super intelligent super like she had a
lot of promise when she was younger but
mental illness kind of [__] her up
later on and then she kind of went off
in a horrible Direction I kind of feel
like she probably killed most of her
boyfriends and husbands which not good
yeah and I feel like was she The
Mastermind behind this she might have
been I feel like she might have
masterminded it but I feel like Bill
rosin was the dude that bu did All Tech
he did all the technical stuff he was
the technical guy because I feel like he
loved her
enough that because the two of them
dated and he seemed to have like a weird
obsession with her yeah so I feel like
anything that she told him to do he
would do it because like later even when
she was like old and quote unquote ugly
like she told him hey I killed my
boyfriend and he's in the freezer like
you know you want to like hide that and
your [__] like he was still so I feel
like there was some kind of [__] going
on there yeah so that's about it on this
case
then we go ahead and wrap this [__] up
it
[Laughter]
right we've been doing this how long has
this show been going on four 4 hours
almost four hours yeah it's time to wrap
this [__] up and I feel like we hardly
ever talked about it no we talked about
the whole [__] case there some people
laughing about you you're fading out
Jenny you're fading out I feel like we
hardly talked about we talked about the
[__] case for four hours you were
talking the whole time was I talking the
whole time people you were talking I was
not talking the whole time we were just
doing a
show that case really wasn't all that
complicated it was just kind of long was
there was so much [__] check out you
talked about it
though you're
triing you're tripping Jenny that's four
hours what you want to talk about it
more want to talk about it for another
hour whatever no we're not going to talk
about this [__] for another era what's
see say seriously everybody's dead Ken
like look she had a lot of accomplice
there were a lot of accomplices there
was Ken Barnes who was like a fishing
buddy of hers quote unquote
that ask me what I put in your drink
nothing I just [__] made her [__]
three really strong drinks she's
loaded everybody say great show seeing
it's that damn
Kela yeah no that's not K she was
drinking she was drinking vodka that's
vodka
yeah yeah do you have anything to say
about I got nothing to say I got nothing
to say
we're going to see these people [__]
when uh couple days right tomorrow
tomorrow we got yeah we got we are
reviewing tomorrow yeah we are reviewing
uncaged yeah that's good movie that
movie watch yeah look see that she's
loaded that [__] is on uh shutter you
watch it it's called uncaged it's a new
movie it's about an escape lion and it's
a [__] Dutch movie it's in yeah it's
dutch yeah it's it's in English and
about a killer lion yeah it's pretty
good it's real good it's kind of like
old school I liked it very much actually
it's kind of like kind of like an ' 80s
movie about a [__] Escape lion eating
people it's got [__] a lot of
practical effects it's good acting it's
just old school like lions biting
people's heads off into it but we'll
talk more about it tomorrow you guys can
[__] be there for the
review all right so uh go ahead and
close it out Jenny say goodbye to
everybody seriously yeah all right all
right seriously Margie margerie deal
Armstrong yeah it's called no it's
called uncaged right uncaged uncaged
it's on shutter they're telling you to
keep drinking
Jenny well I still have this much left
okay no Nicholas Cage isn't in it no
unfortunately no it's a it's a Dutch
movie it's well it's half in like it's a
Dutch movie but it's like half in
English it's on chutter it's a killer
lion movie
yeah if you're into that yeah everybody
says that we're Rock we we're rocking
but uh thanks for thanks for uh [__]
watching the show and uh glad you guys
enjoyed it why don't you [__] meet up
with us tomorrow and we're going to talk
about on caged you can watch that
tonight I know half of you guys are
drinking like us and uh it's a pretty
good trunk watch you'll like it is there
anything you got to say Jenny say
goodbye probably not but you know you
like share And subscribe yeah do all
that [__] do all that [__] and uh
[__] we'll catch you guys
tomorrow yeah we'll be back tomorrow
talking about a killer lion mie yes from
the Netherlands they're saying it's the
best show ever is it it is the best show
ever a they're saying Tom wants to take
Jenny to Pound Town I'd have to fight it
the way she is she's
like no just kid no we good [__] he
doesn't care
listen we'll see guys tomorrow yeah
we'll be back tomorrow hopefully not to
hung over but we'll see you guys
tomorrow talking about a killer lion
movie byebye all right so
bye